finding it easy problem to resolve but
one country has actually cracked it I'm
referring to Australia
what happened at the beginning of this
century was that people began decayed
from Papua New Guinea in small and quite
large boats in some cases to the
Northern Shores of Queensland the then
liberal government decided that the way
to tackle this was to pass an amendment
to his existing migration legislation
not dissimilar to the one that my Noble
friend is introducing today and at the
same time established radically and
newly
an overseas processing center in the
island of narrow in the Solomon Islands
that
the labor government came in and
dismantled which had opposed all this
interesting and I proposed all of this
dismantled it and there was the second
wave the boats came through
the labor government then changed Tac
and began to implement the liberal
policies which he'd previously opposed
too late it was a general election a
liberal government was returned on a
policy called Sovereign boats and
Sovereign National sovereignty and then
as a result of that it it produced a
more thorough going
version of the original policies as a
result of that
the labor government changed his tune
and that policy which did stop the votes
completely has crossed party support and
on the basis of that Australia has
produced a very methodical and rational
uh totally
cross-party support from population
immigration looking at the number of
people each year it wants to allow into
the country those who want to come into
to students the students those who want
to come in for family reasons one's
going to work and so forth It's debated
an annual debate a whole day's debate in
Parliament rather than the date we're
having at the moment and then decisions
are made and the policy is implemented
and it can go up or down the latest
this is the new labor government has
decided to increase the level of
migration going down but within a
framework which is cross has cross-party
support and is certainly supportive
obviously that I wouldn't pretend that
there's big differences between
Australia and this country obviously
that is so and legal differences in
geographical distances but nonetheless
it's important to look
not just parochially what we do but
across the world of what is being done
it does seem to me that that they are
have done something very wise that we
could well implement
and um
the thing I talked at some length over
the last year about how they did it and
what they do do stress to me it was
essential that they did deny to illegal
immigrants the possibility of being an
asylum they denied it to them and
secondly they can transfer them to the
Solomon Islands to the overseas
processing center at great speed and
that essentially is what we are trying
to do here turn the situation around
very rapidly within the framework of
British laws which are different from
Australian laws now those were posing
the uh Governor's policy tend to argue
that we need new Pathways for legal
immigration and I entirely agree what we
have at the moment is rather
unsatisfactory and it's too specific to
particular countries it's too narrow and
we need to expand it and have it a more
rational approach but the truth is we
need to do that and we also need
policies to deter we need both we need a
belt and braces to use a Lancaster and
phrase we need a belt and braces
approach to this otherwise we will not
we will not succeed I made this point
incidentally when the we had a debate on
December the 9th which the primate the
alphabetical Canterbury initiated good
for him because we do need debates on
this talkative immigration and he argued
that it was right to have more legal
Pathways because if you did have a new
low-cost way of getting here it would
demolish the the model of the
traffickers they would no longer be in
business sadly that is not the case as
my Noble friend Lord Howard pointed out
early early in this debate if you get a
new way of coming here the people who
don't get onto that route will find a
way of going via the private method
either because they can't get onto the
route or they don't want to get onto the
route or they find it more congenial to
come via private methods whatever it is
you will not kill off the traffickers
trade if you simply offer more legal
routes you have to have a deterrent as
well there's also a bigger picture I
think we also to mention which sometimes
the noble Lord Lord pilot mentions
rightly this is a small number the big
numbers are the 700 000 or so people who
are coming across legally and we have to
look at them and take up the bigger
picture and ensure my Noble friend Lord
Hodgson will will elucidate in his
remarks we do need to look at that
bigger picture this is a small beginning
but if we can get this right and get
public trust back then we can also
tackle the bigger problem
I'll answer my level friend or horrible
boys talks about a lot of good sense and
I'm very pleased to be able to follow
him the house will be aware that I have
a long standing interest in about
absolute numbers that there is a number
that this country can sustain either
permanently or can absorb on an annual
basis not so many where they come from
what they are it's just that they are
people and they make demands on our
space whatever whatever our space may be
and so it will come with no surprise
a bill like this which he calls one
offers the primary objective restricting
illegal migration this country has my
support and offers I seems to me to
offer a a good line of approach now I'm
aware very much aware that this leads to
one being described at best as heartless
uh I have to say my Lawns I reject that
I'm as aware as any other member of the
House
what Dreadful seconds is are many other
countries and citizens other countries
live nevertheless however difficult
however painful we have to set this
whole issue in context
because sadly the debate about levels of
migration which are
inevitable there's lots of increase in
our population have become rather
lopsided
dominated by two groups both of which
favor increasing the rate
the first scuba discard is the moral
case which is the underlying background
uh honor speeches today and the other is
the economic case of people to film jobs
let me quote from a recent magazine
article and I quote the left hates
talking about immigration
because it thinks any kind
of controls anywhere are racist
the right has been running an economy
depending in part on endless reserves of
imported labor which doesn't like
talking about
however few things are more corrosive
to the public trust than pretending a
problem isn't there sooner or later the
Public Notices
where did that come from
it is Mr Andrew Marr in the news
Statesman of this week
now I don't often quote the new
Statesman a Mr Andrew Barr with approval
but I have to say I think they've got
this bang on the button
no of course both the arguments have
marriage but what is lacking is any
counterview expressed on behalf of the
67.3 million people already set up here
18 of whom come from Minority ethnic
groups their concerns are of course
include economic worries but also wide
range what I call Quality of Life
factors access to open space damage to
our ecology and our environment ability
to achieve our climate change goals our
future food and water security increased
pressure on Education Health and Social
Services and our impact on social
cohesion generally
in February this year I commissioned
some polling all these points and if any
member of the Lordships are happily send
them to them it revealed that across all
ages all social grades all regions of
the United Kingdom and all voting
preferences about 60 were concerned
about future population growth 51 short
version thought should be a cap on the
level net migration at over 60 were
concerned that the government had no
plan in place to consider this
since the Blair government first allowed
perhaps encouraged large-scale migration
the population that the UK has gone up
by eight million people according to
three sidges the size of Manchester as
Europe has succeeded here
governments including my own have
explained away the successively higher
figures as being a series of one-off
events but these one-off events have
kept on coming and the British people
have been presented with their serious
fata company and if we as a part do not
find ways to address these concerns
wider and less attractive spirits will
inevitably begin to make the running
in addition to the general direction of
trump this bill begins to address the
problem in two specific ways first in
Clause 51 for the first time
instituting a total cap on numbers a cap
which will be drawn up after
consultation with local authorities and
be debated in Poland and in this
connection I would like to play a very
sincere tribute to Stephen kinnick the
opposition spokesman in the House of
Commons joined the committee stage when
he gave the labor party support to the
idea of a cap
and secondly the bill offers feds there
will be no reward or Advantage for
economic migrants getting on the boat
across the channel and so jump the queue
the British people as a whole are gyms
but they also place a good deal of
Reliance on fans and the bill offers
this
to conclude my lords the house can take
one of two approaches it can form the
line of more panic and deny the
existence of any problem or at least
deny the existence if only people like
Lord Hodgson stop talking about issues
an attempt to water down the bill so it
becomes ineffective or it can recognize
the very deeply held views and concerns
of our fellow citizens and work to
ensure that we respond to them
four consecutive conservative speakers
and and with respect I have more in
common with the first of those four with
baroness helich than I have with the
subsequent three
Baron has rightly that quoted the
statement that Lord Murray repeated in
this chamber in the 8th of March
and let me quote from Hansard from the
minister repeating the statement let us
be honest by some counts there are a
hundred million people around the world
who could qualify for protection under
under our current laws let us be clear
they are coming here
but this was not honest and the minister
clarified and corrected the record later
in the proceedings
globally at the end of 2022 there were
101 million forcibly displaced people
around the world the majority of which
are internally displaced within their
own countries support for which the UK
has slashed humanitarian assistance to
by up to 60 percent
Global figures of those seeking Asylum
is 4.9 million they are still not coming
here
but the one percent who are seeking come
here against the narrative which my
Noble friend baroness Kramer so
eloquently pointed out that states that
they have values that are odds with us
or that they will cannibalize our
society
but now we are being asked to ban claims
of Asylum because of the method of their
arrival rather than the merits of their
claim
the House of Commons Library showed that
the percentage of Asylum applicants
refused at initial decision reached its
high point in 2004 at 88 since then the
refusal rate has been falling overall
and was just 24 in 2022 its lowest point
since 1990
so much of this debate has been saying
we have an emergency crisis now but we
have the most successful level of Asylum
Justified asylum in 30 years
now for some on the opposite benches we
say that this is because of judicial
Activision but as the noble and love of
Lord Atherton said that the commencement
of the debate we actually have tighter
restrictions now than we ever have
so if you are a young Iranian woman
threatened to be poisoned in a college
or a young Sudanese woman fleeing a
threats of rape from the Wagner group in
Sudan
the government now is Banning Asylum
from them because there are no safe and
legal routes from those two countries
and the government needs to be clear
there are no safe and legal routes but
their obfuscation comes time and time
again I think the government does find
it hard to defend the lack of safe and
legal Roots that's why they are
obfuscating
the minister
has stated in this debate at the start
and he declined to take an intervention
from EBT referred as Lord Armitage who I
greatly respect references to the global
scheme the UK resettlement for
vulnerable refugees scheme and say this
is open to anyone from around the world
but what the government doesn't say is
that the this is operated through the
unhcr but the government doesn't say
that the home office has asked the unhcr
to have that scheme prioritized for
Afghans only
so therefore it is limiting it for
others the independent commission for
Aid impact who did a review said and I
quote from their report in March as a
result the UK RS has almost completely
ceased processing vulnerable refugees
for your settlement to the UK in effect
closing a rare safe and legal route to
seek protection in the UK for refugees
who do not fall under a
nationality-based scheme
not only are we asked to for the first
time in our nation's history to end the
ability to claim Asylum we are reducing
UK support in the very troubled areas
people are seeking safety from
and the government
doesn't believe that there are
consequences for this either
so I want to raise something
not yet mentioned in the debate today
in the 1990s the UK opposed scoring
in-country support roof for refugees as
overseas development assistance but this
is allowed for Nanda odier rules
ten years ago this was a negligible
amount in 2021 it made up nine percent
of all UK Oda and ikai estimates that
now this is one-third because the
government unique amongst all developed
Nations is scoring all of the domestic
support under overseas development
assistance
this means that we are now for the first
time spending more overseas aid in the
UK than on bilateral programs addressing
the root causes of the issues that we've
been debating in this debate today and
because of the unlawful 0.5 percent Cuts
this is now capped
it means that when the government and
the minister says that the Cur the
country is generous and welcome I agree
with them it is that
but if you see you seek Asylum
a shelter in a storm as Churchill
described it
you and if you are a child who doing so
you will be denied and you will be
locked up before you are sent away
and we won't even listen to your case
and generous
well let me tell the house that when it
came to the Ukraine scheme the
government trumpeted quite rightly it's
thank you payments for families 350
pounds which has now been increased
per family Holston Ukrainian refugee
this has scored 100 on overseas
development assistance which means that
the government doesn't tell the family
that that thank you payment has been cut
from children Starving in hunger in the
Horn of Africa or those who are fleeing
conflict abroad I think the government
knows that the public are not on this
side that's why they're not telling the
full picture
this bill has no moral basis we should
not be legislating for it and we are
causing more damage around the world
which will make the problem even greater
[Music]
yeah my lords I think we can all agree
that this is a complicated and
contentious issue which generates strong
views
but maybe we could start with a part of
this bill with which there may be some
agreements the government's indication
that it wants to consider opening more
safe legal routes for those in genuine
need of assignment in this country the
bill states that once passed and the
number of illegal migrants starts to
fall the government intends to look at
possible new safe routes an annual cap
will be agreed each year in consultation
with local authorities to determine what
capacity there is which is vital but in
the event of any humanitarian emergency
it's made quite clear the cap can of
course be amended
this is surely as it should be providing
as much safety and support for those
having to flee from threats violence and
maltreatment as we have the capacity to
manage
but the biggest obstacle to this is the
growing number of illegal migrants who
arrive here some in lorries but mostly
in boats these days if Court tried to
enter the country and many are not they
often claim to be under threat in their
home country when in fact they are
economic migrants intent on taking
advantage of what this country can offer
they pay huge sums of money to people
some others to get them here traveling
through safe countries on the way why
don't they seek the right to settle in
them and then jumping the cues of those
in genuine need who have been waiting
their turn to come here the number of
illegal migrants has quadrupled in the
last four years
last year around 45 000 illegal migrants
arrived by boat
that's slightly more than the equivalent
population of two siren sisters the term
near to where I live
so if we don't control our borders
better how will we keep finding more and
more space every year of whether to two
sound ancestors to build extra
accommodation for that number of illegal
migrants which is increasing every year
meanwhile we read almost daily in our
newspapers about a growing housing
shortage it's becoming a serious problem
so regarding our immigrant numbers in
this context there are those who are
here legally and require housing some
half a million net over the past seven
years which is a major added pressure
but there are also those many thousands
who have no legal right to be here they
also have to be accommodated while their
claims slowly work their way through the
legal system at huge extra cost and no
benefit to the taxpayer this is an
example of how illegal immigration makes
it more difficult for this country to
make provision for those genuine legal
assignment Seekers who we want to
support
my lords we must put the people's
Smugglers who encourage illegal migrancy
out of business
enforcing new laws laid out in this bill
would permit Speedy removal of all those
illegal migrants they have brought to
him as a result fewer and fewer of their
passengers would think that what the
Smugglers offer would be worth a huge
amount of money they charge to bring
them here and the dangerous risks
attached to the journey wouldn't be
worth it either
the Prime Minister told a news
conference back in March that since a
deal was agreed with the Albanian
government to take back Albanian illegal
migrants whom we now fly back promptly
the number of albanians come here
illegally has already fallen
significantly
the change in the law to allow the
prompt removal of illegal migrants in
this country is Central to how we go
forward they will either be flown
straight back home if safe or to Rwanda
which has been identified as a suitable
alternative if they don't wish to return
to their country of origin
outstanding legal claims to live here in
the UK will have to be taken up from
where the claims are resettled
I would like to Echo the concerns
expressed by my Noble friend Lord
Sandhurst about proposals concerning
modern slavery however and I would like
to ask my Noble friend the minister if
there is a possibility those proposals
can be reconsidered so that those
already victims of modern slavery in
this country can safely report their
condition without being sent home
finally my laws the general purpose of
this bill is to deter illegal migrants
from setting out in the first place and
no legal entry will be granted except in
special circumstances to those who have
already tried to enter illegally
previously we must deter them from
trying and stop the Smugglers making
money out of Misery we need to change
the law to do so we cannot leave things
as they are
English debates the noble or the
minister said our broken Asylum system
is costing the country some 3 billion
pounds a year
home secretaries since the 12th of May
2010 Theresa May Amber Rudd such a Javed
pretty Patel Sheila braveman Grant chaps
and Zoella blademan again
which one of those does the noble Lord
the minister hold responsible for our
self-described broken Asylum system or
all of them
now
uh my Noble friend Bernice Jones and
moskins covered the general horrors of
this in defensible Bill I'm going to
focus on some of the actual people the
individuals who will be caught by it two
who will be subjected to what can only
be described as utterly unacceptable
inhumane abusive treatment
now the night below the minister in the
introduction said 70 of the children are
arriving are aged over 16. so they would
only spend two years or less warehoused
here in the UK before the time for happy
birthday your president present is a
deportation flight
of course that means that 30 of cases
will be facing more than two years in
that situation of warehousing an
eight-year-old a ten-year-old a 12 year
old what would such a situation the full
knowledge of such a fate do to their
health and well-being that that
treatment breaks the UN convention on
the rights of the child is only a
statement of the obvious
now as Noble ladies baroness Lister and
Sugg and others have highlighted
pregnant refugees are also trapped by
this bill the small but important
Victory won by cross-party campaigns in
2016 to exclude them from immigration
detention wiped out
yeah they're babies will be born into
indefinite detention
how long will they stay in that
situation
how inhuman is the government prepared
to be
now people with mental health conditions
refugees who arrived here with
conditions often induced by torture or
War who develop or who develop them as a
result of our hostile environment
a direct question to the noble law of
the minister has he read the detailed
forensic examination of the impacts of
bill from the Royal College of
psychiatrists It quotes the sure review
that immigration detention has a
negative impact on detainees mental
health and the impact on Mental Health
increases the longer the tension
continues
now as many noble Lords have said
there's the victims of modern slavery
and trafficking and this Royal College
report points out how frequently they
understandably suffer from difficult to
treat complex PTSD
what will the indefinite potential or
removal to Rwanda do to them and picking
up that group I'm indebted to the noble
lady baroness Kenny of the shores for
some information from an impeccable
Source unpublished home offers
information that says that shows there
is already an outrageous persistent
slavery Survivor protection Gap
of the 11
137 confirmed cases of trafficking and
modern slavery survivors referred for
consideration for discretion relief to
remain in the six years and nine months
from April 16 to December 22.
I'll repeat the figure 1137.
only 738
7 have been granted leave to remain
far from refugees gaming the system we
have a system that already is a lottery
and what this bill does is takes away
any chance for those people to establish
a secure life for themselves
now picking up again focusing on people
who will particularly suffer under this
bill as the noble Lord Lord Ethan said
lgbti QA plus refugees Rwanda is not
safe for them nor are many of the other
theoretical countries to which they
might be stripped
now some might say that the people I
have listed who are particularly
vulnerable and not the majority of
refugees who reach our Shores by
non-orderly means as the noble Lord the
minister said an overwhelming majority
of the arrivals were adult males under
the age of 40.
that's a fact men like the refugee now
settled in Norway to whom the noble Lord
Lord Paddock referred
but what did the ventures opposite have
against young men
most of them were young men once
not anymore
I finish with a couple of General points
arising from the debate first as
baroness pressure scene Asylum is a
collective responsibility of all states
as the unhcr is the Council of Europe
commissioner foreign human rights among
many others have pointed out if other
nations followed the lead of this bill
there would be a breakdown in the
International System of Refuge
secondly again highlighting the words of
the neighborhood Lord Lord Everton this
is not a small boat spill the provisions
of this bill would affect all who seek
Refugee status in this country it is a
comprehensive anti-refugee bill
and finally the noble Lord Forsyth of
drumlee who unfortunately is not in his
place quoted John Stuart Mill
bad men need to nothing nothing more to
Compass their ends than that good men
should look on and do nothing
I think is a very useful reflection on
the amendment to this motion
the bid by the liberal Democrats which
has wholehearted greens backing to stop
this bill now today in its tracks
we've heard all the usual reasons the
excuses why we shouldn't we're only a
house of review we're only an unelected
house
well I'm going to repeat a question that
I put to part four of what's now the
police act the part that explicitly
targets Gypsy Roma and traveler people
a direct question to those planning on
voting against the amendment or the or
abstaining on stopping this bill
is there nothing
you would stop
where do you draw the line
surely you have a line
yeah yeah
uh my my lords as other speakers have
said we are now living an age of mass
migration and as Lord Haig often says
the population of Africa and the Middle
East is expected to increase by about 1
million people by the middle of this
century
of course this country has benefited
over the centuries from immigration
but this is now an increasingly crowded
island with all that means for for our
already hard-pressed housing and public
services
for many years debate on this subject is
often conflated economic migrants with
genuine Asylum Seekers
which is why it's absolutely right that
this bill distinguishes legal from
illegal migration
this very difficult issue is not one
faced only by this country as many of
you know you only have to look at Italy
Greece France and Germany to see that
and our recent agreements with France
and Algeria reflect in the important
recognition of that reality
for government recognizes that the
current Asylum system isn't working
as you've heard there's a backlog of 160
000 cases
more than two billion pounds a year has
been spent on accommodation
and apparently there are more than 80
000 people who've illegally entered the
UK since 2018. having often traveled
through multiple safe countries to reach
the UK
our so-called pull factor
so I welcome this bill as do a majority
of our citizens it's the government's
genuine attempt
to remedy our current broken system
today we have heard from
various sections of this house plenty of
outrage but very little by way of
alternative workable Solutions
solutions to this admittedly very
difficult problem
as an earlier speaker said it's about
deterrence to cut off demand from the
organized criminal gangs gaming and
profiteering from our current system
and I agree with that
no doubt this bill can be improved here
but it should not be mold unrecognizably
yeah
that would not be understood or accepted
in my view by a majority of our citizens
it's little in this bill that I can
agree with other than the broad premise
that we must control the dangerous
Channel Crossings and end the business
model of the people's Smugglers but the
term stopped the boat does not
accurately reflect the wide-ranging
impact of this bill on Asylum Seekers
and refugees by whichever mode of Entry
to the UK
it is a hugely complex issue and it
would be good to hear from the home
office what strategy they are building
to identify true need from those just
wishing to take advantage of the system
and what efforts are being made to
establishing safe and legal routes
the current backlog in processing those
already here and the cost to the
taxpayer is clearly not acceptable and
it requires resource and efficiency on
the part of the home office to clear
but if we seek to close our borders to
those fleeing persecution without even
allowing them a hearing then what we are
saying is that we are outside the
principles of international cooperation
on which the global Refugee system is
based
we are in danger of criminalizing
incarcerating forcing statelessness
homelessness and destitution on genuine
Asylum Seekers many of whom are already
traumatized on arrival
there are 34 million refugees and Asylum
seekers in the world today with Millions
more internally displaced the vast
majority are being hosted by those
countries which border the conflict
areas
I have seen the rohingya refugee camps
at Cox's Bazaar in Bangladesh
I have seen the vast Refugee container
camps in gazian tip
on the Turkish Syrian border and the
Syrian refugee camps in Jordan a country
already hosting Palestinian refugees for
many decades
it is international cooperation which is
key to solving one of the biggest issues
that the world is facing the mass
movement of people due to conflict but
also because of climate change
the United Nations High commission for
refugees has categoric categorically
stated that if the illegal migration
bill is enacted in its current form it
would break the UK's obligations under
the refugee convention
and would significantly undermine the
international Refugee protection system
which needs support by all members
we cannot just throw up our hands and
opt out of a system that we were front
and center in helping shape because
things have become difficult our
International reputation must be
preserved because respect from and
collaboration with the International
Community is Paramount for the future
success of Britain we have always prided
ourselves on our sense of fairness and
capacity to protect those in need
and I would hope that we would wish to
leave this good reputation for future
Generations
our belief in the moral imperative to be
open in Minds hearts and actions my
lords the children's commissioner who
has a statutory duty to protect the
rights of children in England including
those who have arrived in the in the
country fleeing from Modern persecution
has stated that the bill undermines
other legislation as in the children's
Act of 1989.
I would say to my Noble friend Minister
let's not forget that it was a
conservative LED government under David
Cameron
which ended child detention and which
quadruple locked it into legislation in
the 2014
Immigration Act the safeguards and
protections under that legislation are
being removed under this bill
the off-tailed belief that many claiming
to be children are over the age of 18
and thus adults is flawed as last year
alone 850 children were wrongly assessed
as adults and sent to adult
accommodation and detention centers
which put them directly In Harm's Way
the refugee and migrants children's
Consortium says of this bill the
proposals will leave children locked out
of claiming Refugee protection detained
removed if unaccompanied accommodated by
the home office outside the established
care system if a victim of trafficking
or child of such a victim unprotected
and denied their citizenship rights
children will be left in limbo for years
unable to access any form of status or
to rebuild their lives
and I would add with the very real
threat of being deported to Rwanda when
they reached the age of 18.
these most vulnerable young people are
affected at a time in their life where
there are deep and Lasting consequences
similarly the modern slavery Act of 2015
enacted under another conservative prime
minister Theresa May is also being
compromised in this bill
my Lord I would also like to add that
some of the language used in The Other
Place whilst debating this bill has been
deeply unhelpful
in fact I am dismayed The Narrative that
the home office has adopted
stigmatizing and stereotyping people
wherever they come from and under
whichever circumstances will do little
to advance our aim to manage this most
difficult issue we all wish to see
prosperity and security for our country
but I hope with our principles and
values intact we must be on the right
side of doing the right thing
the disquiet this discomfort so many of
us feel whether we can adequately
articulate or not is indicated in how
many of us
are participating in second reading of
this bill I hope that my Noble friend
Minister will take note
my lords the more I listen to this
debate and particularly to my Noble
friend Lord Carlisle of beru
the more strongly I'm convinced that
this bill is morally questionable
legally doubtful
and totally unworkable
but setting to one side these wider
challenges of the bill
I would like to focus attention on the
impact the bill would have on miners
whether accompanied or not
as we have heard particularly from Lord
Howarth of newpod
the bill proposes that these children if
not immediately deported
may be accommodated by the home office
outside the established care system
upon reaching the age of 18 they will be
deported to a third country
with which they most likely have no
existing ties and will face a lifetime
ban from entering Britain
accompany children were not given the
right to remain will also be barred from
the UK for life
despite this disproportionate punishment
for the children
I don't believe it would even act as a
deterrent
and the noble Minister said that the
purpose of the bill is supposed to be a
deterrent
people desperate enough to take to the
boats are not going to be put off by
punishment that could be enacted many
years into the future
it's quote the refugee and migrant
children's Association
also undoes decades worth of progress
made under the conservative government
reversing the ending of child attention
and protections for child victims of
trafficking
Lord Forsyth of Drumline complained that
no one is providing Solutions
but neither is this bill a solution
is not going to solve the migration
crisis
this is just going to add to the massive
backlog of cases waiting to be processed
I too agree with my Noble friend Lord
Kerr of King lockout that the solution
can be found in centers in France
as we all know there is a growing
illegal migration crisis
we all know that something needs to be
done about it
but to attempt a solution that penalizes
children
is misguided in the extreme
it's not how a civilized society treats
the most vulnerable
my Lord as always in your lordship's
house it's a great pleasure to be part
of a debate which no matter which side
one stands on and the issue marks the
breadth of the expertise and opinion in
this chamber it's an expertise I respect
and also respect for the strength of
feeling on the bill from all sides that
strength of feeling is because the house
does reflect the public debate that is
taking place outside of Parliament
I'm speaking in support of the progress
of this bill not because I take some
pleasure in ever more stringent Asylum
policy but and to perhaps answer the
noble Lord Lord purpose I want to secure
safe and legal routes based on a
humanitarian need and that provides a
moral imperative for this bill to
succeed and be improved
my Lord's public policy must always rely
on a contract and consent with and from
the British people without that consent
government is perilous government should
be able to articulate the values of this
country and welcoming humanitarian
refugees in a constant evolving policy
based on humanitarian need at the moment
my lords this country is Asylum policy
is in a state of stasis or at best a
reactive State a reactive policy that
requires public response before
government will act a totemic tragedy
such as a shock when the washed up body
of the two-year-old Alan kurdy
galvanized the government to Institute a
resettlement policy of twenty thousand
syrians likewise the Ukrainian and Hong
Kong resettlement schemes of which we're
all proud have all been implemented
fully because of public consent and
reaction
meanwhile the Afghan scheme free
settlement which seems so important to
everyone in August 2021 seems to have
stalled quite dramatically in its
initial aims
this start stop policy of bespoke
schemes my lords does not represent the
values or implementation of a truly
humanitarian policy blind to race or
geopolitics why my lords do we think
that our policy has fallen into this
stop-start approach to Asylum and away
from Universal legal roots
the first reason has to be the failure
of our Asylum bureaucracy and lack of
resource to process claims the prime
minister is prioritizing that process
with extra staffers and support and that
has to be welcomed backlogs not only
create needless anxiety for those
seeking Asylum but also destroy public
confidence in the system
that public confidence is I'm afraid why
this legislation is required
from 300 Asylum Seekers arriving in
small boats in 2018 we've now reached 45
000.
the toxin of this seeming lack of
control and unfairness then denigrates
all Asylum Seekers across the world
for those of us who want to ensure safe
legal routes based on humanitarian need
it is very difficult to find the public
consent necessary to permeate public
policy Beyond bespoke schemes I've
already spoken about before 2018 there
was an opening after the success of the
Syrian resettlement scheme for wider
schemes in conjunction with the unhcr
but that discussion and debate has been
Paralyzed by illegal Crossings pushed by
the malevolent people traffickers
so my lords I accept the government must
make every effort to stop the boats if
we are to see an expansion of the legal
routes and a humanitarian basis that the
vast majority of us in your Lordships
house would want to see if we do not use
all legislative tools at our disposal
and rebuild public confidence I don't
believe any government conservative
labor or even a labor lib Dem amalgam
will be able to fully Implement a
humanitarian legal route process with
public consent
and it is this legal process that I hope
my Noble friend and Minister will be
able to put further flesh in the bones
to maximize support in this house
as well as the survey of accommodation
of local authorities to identify its cap
I would ask that the government give
further commitments to work with unhcr
and that that work forms part of the
regular statement the Home Secretary
lays before Parliament I want to hear as
we progress this bill a commitment given
that there will be identified routes to
offer Asylum to humanitarian Asylum
Seekers wherever they come from in the
world
transparency in a new process will
provide the sunshine and hygiene
required to build public confidence and
rebuild pride in our humanitarian policy
in this country
that is not to say in the future my Lord
so there will not need to be a bespoke
policies responding to crisis across the
world but they cannot be the basis for
our Asylum policy there are always going
to be vulnerable people who will not
have the media Focus required to launch
a bespoke scheme in this country there
must be a credible answer to the
question Tim Lawton MP asked the Home
Secretary at the home Affairs select
committee on the routes for those
without width and to use a good Scottish
word out with at the bespoke schemes the
government will have to provide further
Assurance to get more support in your
lordship's house now Lord this bill is
sadly necessary if we're to help the
most vulnerable across the world I will
not be able to support the noble Lord
Lord paddocks fatal motion later if it
were to be successful I feel that the
very people that need us to act for them
would see the safe and legal routes at
scale required becoming an Ever more
distant Prospect
my loads it's a bit much to be lectured
on what is constitutional what's not
constitutional when this bill likes so
many other recent bills impinges on what
ought to be the rights and duties of
devolved Administrations
it's further evidence that the UK
government would happily undo the
arrangement of the past 20 plus years
and reduce or remove the powers of the
other parliaments
they might not be
um quite as ready as the noble Lord Lord
Frost is not in his place at this point
when he wrote recently on Devolution
that it was time to stop
his criticism was that the electors in
Wales and Scotland kept voting for the
wrong parties
the spur towards Devolution was of
course the fact that for many years
Scotland and Wales rejected the
conservative party but had no way of
mitigating the impact of Westminster
legislation until the referendums in
1997.
the difference between the Welsh and
Scottish governments and the UK
government has never been a stark as in
their approach to people seeking
Sanctuary through Asylum and immigration
on this issue the conservative party has
no support outside or out with its own
ranks and even many of them must be
mortally embarrassed
the rights established by the European
convention on human rights are written
into this into Scotland's Devolution
settlement and have been fundamental to
the work of the Scottish Parliament over
20 years
the conventions incorporation provides
fundamental safeguards that ensure that
in
Scotland executive powers can't be
abused Scottish ministers cannot act in
a way that's incompatible with the
convention and all its legislation must
be compatible
I think in this chamber there is a clear
consensus that the bill will reach the
convention and leaves the Scottish
parliament in an invidious position
under international law
those involved in human rights in
Scotland have described the bill as
creating
an urgent human rights emergency and the
Scottish Refugee Council condemns it as
morally repugnant practically unworkable
and that it will have severe impacts on
women men and children seeking safety
just right Scotland describes the bill
as cruel and necessary and unlawful and
that this bill condemns people to living
a life of limbo and strips them of all
support
the government's delegated power
memorandum makes it clear that the
functions of local Authority in respect
have looked after children are devolved
math our devolved matter
this is recognized in Clauses 15 to 18
which state that they only apply in
England but there is a very real threat
contained in Clause 19 which states that
the Secretary of State
may make regulations in the future on
closes 15 to 18 to apply in the devolved
administrations using secondary
legislation again
closes 23 and 24 the bill will remove
duties and powers that currently obliged
the devolved Administrations
to provide support and assistance to
victims of trafficking and their
families
including children
instead it will attempt to compel
devolved Nations to violate the duties
set out in international law this is
contrary to Scottish legislation set out
in the human trafficking and
exploitation Scotland Act of 2015.
in almost all other countries this bill
could not be tabled as it breaches
treaty obligations and is contrary to
basic human rights
if the UK had such a thing as a written
Constitution this would be unacceptable
it's the powers of Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland were protected this
would not be allowed to happen under
this government were expected sorry
we're experiencing endless bills that
contravene natural Justice and encroach
on Devol Powers at some point we have to
say this must stop
this bill should be where we draw the
line and say not in our name
yeah
my Lord's one of the advantages of
speaking relatively late on in a debate
such as this is the forge one the
opportunity to hear so many
contributions from your Lordships and
the passionate positions that many of
you quite understandably have but I
would suggest I would say uh that
actually on the whole this debate has
been conducted in a very even-handed way
and I congratulate my Noble friend the
minister for setting the tone right at
the outset of this a debate such as this
was always going to be emotional and
controversial and I think on that at
least we can all agree
my lords I looked at the uh fatal
Amendment table by the noble Lord Lord
Paddock
um and I will not be supporting it
although I think it includes some
interesting uh points because I believe
that this bill the proper place for this
bill is now to go to committee where the
bill can be properly scrutinized and
where necessary improved and I totally
agree with the noble Lord Lord Coker who
said that your lordship should not be
cowed or intimidated by the other place
it is surely our role to do exactly what
we're about to do otherwise it seems to
me we have no point at all and I don't
think we need chat GPT to tell us that
that having been said I entirely concur
with the view of my Noble friend Lord
Sherburne uh who pointed out that this
bill with amendments has already gone
through the other place
and it is a key part of the government's
policy to stop the boats and we should
bear that in mind as we go into
committee
the noble Lord Lord dubs who is in his
place spoke about one of the points that
Lord Paddock had in his favor in his
fatal Amendment 0.4 about a failure to
include the measures to eliminate the
backlog of Asylum cases
and I would just like to press my Noble
friend the minister on this because it
seems to me this is one of the worst
problems that we have uh confronting us
today it's a stain on our national
character our inability to process those
who are already here leaving many of
them in in a kind of a No Man's Land
waiting for uh their future to be
decided in conditions that frankly in
some places are deplorable so is it uh
because of the legal challenges which
are mounted each and every time a case
comes up and if so how will this bill
change that or is it the incompetence of
those who are tasked with processing
this or is it of lack of resources and
if it's a lack of resources can the
minister commit to committing more
resources because it seems to be the
part of any bill should address those
that are already here another point
though Paddock made on 0.5 was the
failure to include measures to tackle
people smuggling gangs well the whole
idea of this bill is that there will be
no need for people smuggling gangs if we
can get it out there that once you come
here illegally you will not be able to
come here again but we need to make sure
that message goes out loud and clear I
remember the human trafficking Bill the
foreign office was tasked all around the
world with having endless campaigns of
bringing this to the Public's attention
and the locality of whether foreign
officer based they should be tasked once
more again once the spill becomes law
which I believe it will do in actually
pointing the new legislation out all
around the world that if people come
here illegally they will not be able to
stay here
the most reverent primate the Archbishop
of Canterbury reminded us of the huge
increase in displaced people many
millions more anticipated by 2050. as a
result of climate change all conflict
and we're seeing today what's happening
in the Sudan and if we believe that
climate change is going to get worse
pulse waves of sub-Saharan Africa will
become uninhabitable and we talk about
the difference between internally
displaced people and displaced people
well I would submit if you can't
actually live somewhere soon those
internally displaced people will have to
seek their lives elsewhere that's going
to have huge migratory pressures so the
result of all this it is incumbent on
that uncumbent on us to have a fair and
enforceable migration policy and frankly
my Lord nothing I've heard this
afternoon or indeed since we started
this debate so just to me that any of
those who've been criticizing this bill
have come up with a credible workable
alternative
see we are left my Lord with a policy
which is neither fair to those already
here or those seeking to come here
through legal channels this is
manifestly not fair uh to anyone
and I would just point out finally on
the subject of Rwanda and the greens
some seem to have something against a
Rwanda were those of us who went to
Rwanda for chogham the Commonwealth
heads of government meeting there last
year saw a very different country I
believe to that which is being depicted
by some whose knowledge of the country
is perhaps a little bit second hand or
out of date it's known as the
Switzerland of Africa and I I believe
that it's a well-placed country to
receive Asylum uh Seekers what I would
just say to my honorable friend the
minister is I just like to tease out of
him a little bit more about the deal
room with Rwanda and what discussions
the government have had with the
government in Rwanda about the
guaranteed freedom of people who we are
sending there and also the ability of
those people once they are there to
return to their own homelands if that is
what they seek to do
by Lords I shall not detain you uh much
longer but I would just end by saying
this
too long as a country as a government a
successive government we have shirked
our responsibilities
by failing to enact a fair and
enforceable policy on Asylum and
migration
and difficult and controversial although
aspects of this bill most certainly are
I do believe it is a positive move to
address this I therefore welcome this
bill which I will be supporting and my
Lord if not this then what
my Lord amen
can I begin by
saying that I also fully support this
bill
I think it's a necessary bill
and I'd like to also begin by thanking
Unison and the rmt to trade unions for
their briefing
I've noticed over the years how the
labor party no longer seems to mention
unions
possibly there is embarrassed they might
win the next election and then God knows
what they do with this bill because I've
noticed this week they have been back
peddling a bit on what they might do
with legislation that our government is
passing
but the other thing that struck me about
this debate is so much of it you've seen
about refugees and not much about the
people who actually live in Britain
now they're not racist and they don't
dislike people but the fact of the
matter is that this is a matter of
democracy
and the people of Britain are fed up to
the back teeth with a government that
doesn't appear to be able to control the
boats it's as simple as that they're not
against legal migration or legal
immigration
failed one stand how we can have a
government that can't manage to stop a
dinghy in the middle of a bit of sea so
this in many ways is a matter of
democracy and it's a matter of fairness
to many people the people who've
welcomed the refugees from the Ukraine
and Afghanistan
are welcoming them because they're seen
as legitimate refugees these people are
not
and we've heard a lot about
International obligations
we had an international obligation to
the European Union the people revolted
against it
there are all sorts of international
obligations NATO the Council of Europe
the United Nations and while we're at it
could I just remind members that
Churchill who is always quoted for the
camps of Europe
was basically pretty disinterested in it
all of the work on the counts of Europe
was done by Ernie Bevin the labor
foreign secretary Churchill showed
virtually no interest in the Council of
Europe but he did admittedly read read a
couple of speeches which I doubt he
understood
so let's get away from this idea that
somehow Churchill and Maxwell Fife with
a great Godfathers of international
cooperation that can't be broken
time moves on and let me remind you the
refugee
system set up in the late 1940s was to
deal with the forcible removal of German
background citizens from Poland and
Czechoslovakia it was nothing to do with
migration from Africa or anywhere else
like that
I in my earlier years in this house sat
on the Foreign Affairs committee until
the whips decided to get rid of me one
of the things we looked at was Operation
Sofia which was the EU operation on
migrants and the subcommittee made the
title of our report operations of fear a
failed operation because we found that
we couldn't control the boat in the
Mediterranean
and my main worry about this particular
bill
is not that it's too stringent or
something but that it won't work
and the key to making it work is somehow
the government has got to find a way of
stopping the boats it's as simple as
that
if you don't get across the channel you
won't try and get across the journal but
if you're told you're going to be
waiting for 10 years before you'll be
deported of course you'll come across
the channel because you'll think oh well
there'll be a couple more government
changes before then and they'll probably
get fed up and they'll run out of money
and we'll all be allowed to stay so the
key to this minister is you've got to
work out a way of stopping the boats now
unlike Australia we don't have a nearby
Island where we can put people on you
could try out Ascension Island but I
don't think there's anything much closer
than that so what I would say is that
you have to make it clear
that there is no future in landing in
the UK and the point I want to make on
the two unions I mentioned is that we
must make it clear in this legislation
that it is not going to give powers to
anyone to our social care workers Unison
workers all Railway workers to perform
illegal Acts
they cannot be subject to being asked to
do things which are in any way dubious
and I hope that it will be written in
that there will be an Indemnity for them
if they are so in closing I'm pleased to
support this act I hope it works but the
key is to stop the boats crossing the
channel
yeah
my lords yeah it's a pleasure to follow
the wisdom of my
Noble friend Lord balth
my Lord's defense of the realm is the
first duty of government so this bill is
essential if unpalatable
without control over our own borders
Parliament law making and evidence-based
policy become sideshows
it's not dehumanizing for our government
to strain every sinew to stop the boats
we don't want anyone else dying in a
flimsy boat in our Waters
this trade is doing Untold harm to our
country as well as to those putting
family fortunes and precious lives into
the hands of people Smugglers what is
being traded is not simply money for
unsafe passage it's also our physical
and social infrastructure
many speaking against today's Bill
habitually and rightly hold this
government to account for lack of
Housing and access to essential Services
particularly children's social care but
also family doctors education and
everything else our people rely on for
quality of life
and here may I ask my Noble friend the
minister can he provide any detail as to
the current strain on children's social
services and are there any projections
of how this could worsen without action
one of the first rules of Economics is
wants are unlimited but resources to
satisfy them are limited the Basic
Instinct of many here is to scoop up
scoop up the dispersist especially
vulnerable children and give them the
benefits of living in Britain however
whilst we might want to do that we need
to pay attention to the electorate it is
not pandering to ask what people who
voted for this government want ministers
to prioritize and over two-fifths said
their second greatest concern about the
cost of living after the cost of living
is illegal migration routes such as
small boats more than those who said NHS
waiting lists
we're heading in the right direction in
an incredibly difficult area of social
policy but we cannot be half-hearted the
small boats business model is ruthlessly
pursued therefore this bill must not be
so watered down that the loopholes are
big enough to drive an armada through
the electorates are not closet little
englanders and I choose my words
carefully Scotland has taken a
disproportionately low number of Asylum
Seekers England has stepped up to accept
most of those entering through safe and
legal Global routes on which we have a
proud recent record
we're certainly not ducking out of the
United Nations Refugee convention and
the UK's International responsibilities
as we've heard our country's specific
routes have provided refuge for a
hundred and fifty thousand people from
Hong Kong 160
000 ukrainians 25 000 Afghans forced to
flee the Taliban another fifty thousand
people have come to the UK via
non-specific country routes including
through the family reunion route for
those with a qualifying family member in
the UK
yet 74 as we've heard of illegal
arrivals are adult males many of whom
who came directly from safe countries
such as Albania and all traveled through
safe conscious such as France where they
should have claimed Asylum
neither are the electorate heartless
but they are concerned about the six
million pounds daily costs of housing
illegal migrants and other expenses like
the Manpower needed to deal with them
I'm in and out of prisons and one reason
they find it hard to maintain Staffing
levels is because border Force absorbs
so many of their trained officers
as mentioned earlier people are
particularly concerned about the already
stretched Social Services backdrop for
British children such as the lack of
Foster carers and other pressures which
mean many are placed far from home in
residential settings
those who argue that unaccompanied
children should automatically become
looked after by local authorities and
certainly not be sent back need to be
wide-eyed about the knock-on effect this
is already having
children who are sent on ahead to
benefit from the British system further
strain our social care infrastructure
and make it even harder to address
current failings
Commons amendments mean return only
happens if unaccompanied children's
country of origin is safe or they are to
be reunited with their parents
putting it bluntly if parents are not
dissuaded from sending their
unaccompanied children on these boats
Smugglers will likely Focus their trade
on this new area of weakness
the vast majority of illegal migrants
are not pregnant women and children but
that could change if we do anything to
provide a magnet to attract them we
cannot tread so timidly timidly as to be
ineffectual every day people on the
coast are dealing directly with this
growing problem of illegal migrants who
have to be housed and medically treated
sometimes as a result of their perilous
Journey
this bill will attract I'm sure an
abundance of amendments but these should
not be laid cynically to prevent
progress on small boats before the next
election we and the electorate need
action this day
in other words it's good that there's
one thing that seems to unite the whole
house and that is the fact that we all
deplore the backlog and the uh need for
that to be addressed and the noble lady
Barnet Bennett went on about all the
ex-home secretaries in the conservative
party responsible having gone back much
longer I have to say that during the 13
years of a labor government we had
exactly the same problem and I remember
very much as a constituency MP this was
one of the huge issues that came up Time
After Time
I will be supporting uh this bill's
second reading tonight and will be
opposing the wrecking Amendment uh I
think it is important that the
convention to allow government bills to
have second readings uh are adhered to
um no matter how strongly we may feel
about the legislation and of course
we're going to all have the right to
amend this bill I may even put some down
some amendments myself and we can do
what we normally do which is make those
amendments and vote on them but for me
the principle of the in principal aim of
this legislation is to act to stop the
small boats coming here in the first
place around 18 months ago I had a
three-hour debate here on migrants and
it was very sadly on the day when 27
lives had just been lost crossing the
channel and much was said then about how
that could never be allowed to happen
again
and since then the numbers coming over
have ondingese have escalated to 2021
when I spoke there had been something
that 28 500 comes through already 2022
there were 45
755 and now uh up to from uh 2018 we've
had nearly a hundred thousand people
arrive in our in in at Dover
and I think it is legitimate to say that
our country has lost control of our own
borders and certainly that's what the
public when they look at the television
pictures think we have seen that some of
these new arrivals not many but some
um have been identified as a terrorist
threat and many have disappeared with no
idea where we we have no idea where
they've gone to or what they're up to
and I think the security of our own
country must be a priority of government
as so must the social cohesion of the of
our communities moving hundreds of
mainly young men and I often think where
are all the young women where are all
the women mainly these hundreds of young
men into areas where they will not be
able to intermix is a recipe for
problems and the public are not stupid
nor are the vast majority prejudiced
against genuine Asylum Seekers but they
see at firsthand the impact on their
community and no that it is
unsustainable
and when I visited Dover to see for
myself how the arrivals were protest uh
process some years ago two years ago uh
we cannot ignore the fact uh that what
happens to these people in France or in
many other countries is is very very uh
what how we treat people rather than how
they're treated in those countries is
far superior to what happens elsewhere
so we cannot ignore that there is a pull
factor to the United Kingdom uh
otherwise I still see why so many want
to leave the safe countries that they've
come to to come here of course there's
some with family connections but we do
have a system that operates maybe that
can be looked at to make it better but
that would allow legal entry for them
but those who manage the boats the
people Smugglers are well acquainted
with what happens in our own country
they know there are at least five
different Avenues to challenge a
negative Asylum claim result and if all
that fails another another Asylum claim
can be simply launched in a fresh
application
and then we see someone who commits a
hideous crime like a murder here and is
being deported one of the many agencies
will assemble a mass of MPS and probably
Noble Lords to stop the deportation and
all usually paid for by public money and
legal aid and we cannot go on uh with
people being allowed to bring multiple
claims and judicial reviews
it's a lawyer's Paradise but it's a hard
working British taxpayer bearing the
cost so making it clear is this bill
does that if you come here illegally
then you will not be considered for
Asylum will be a deterrent and that you
will be deported and I I want to see the
commitment given by the Home Secretary
once the small boats have been stopped
the government will look at more safe
and legal routes for General Asylum
Seekers I want that to happen and we
will keep an eye to make sure it does
but we really do need to differentiate
between economic migrants refugees and
Asylum Seekers and even if some people
in in this house do not differentiate
the public differentiates and that is
what important and I think it's also
very important that when people
complained about the language used by
some ministers I think sometimes the
language used by people who are
supporting this bill or make some quite
rational sensible points that then kind
of almost portrayed as being racist I
think we have to be careful about our
language just as much
in my view the reality is that only
tough and unambiguous legislation will
stand any chance of succeeding and
dissuading people from risking their
lives by jumping into dinghies and
heading for Britain in the expectation
that once here they will be permitted to
stay we have to send a signal that we
are not an open door and that we will
not continue to allow the industry of
lawyers making millions from the whole
Asylum system to continue the government
is unwise I think to seek to give the
impression that the bill will solve all
our illegal immigration problems it
won't but it certainly is a start and we
have to try and this bill is now with us
and will with some improvements it
should be supported
my lords stop the boats is actually a
worthy aim and the prime minister is
right to consider it a priority of
government but this bill has currently
written will not achieve that aim let me
assure my Noble friends straight away
that although I have great concerns
about this text I will not be opposing
second reading today
my concerns are numerous and my probing
and questions require some clear answers
from my Noble friend
my remarks are made partly for my
background as an immigration minister in
the UK partly as a former spokesperson
in the European Parliament and partly as
a lawyer not a lefty lawyer I begin by
telling my Noble friend that the ways
chosen by the government to alleviate
the undoubted suffering of persecuted
people fleeing tyranny will actually
have the opposite outcomes to those
suggested and in implementation will
both break solemn laws and treaties and
provide greater sustenance to the real
criminals the people traffickers and
Smugglers who should be our first
targets
the number of detected human trafficking
offenses has increased substantially in
recent years means not allow them to
profit from vulnerable people
why are we not doing more to catch these
real criminals some of whom are actually
here in the UK
as a lawyer my Noble friend must
understand that I will never vote in
favor of our government breaking the law
and I trust that is the same situation
for him
the government has claimed that it has
taken advice from the finest legal Minds
in this country can he please name These
Fine legal minds and to clarify I'm
satisfied as is the unhcr and other
organizations that no Asylum Seeker per
se can be illegal there is a clear
difference as my Noble friend ought to
know between migrants who come here
illicitly or deceitfully and are in
breach of our tight immigration rules
and Asylum Seekers Who present here and
claim Asylum under the criteria the
strict criteria of the 1951 U.N
convention on refugees in the first case
those that break our immigration rules
should and must be deported speedily in
the second case applications for Asylum
should be quickly put to proof that they
meet the fundamental criteria to be
granted Refuge if they cannot they then
should be returned to whence they came
when I was minister in 1996 I committed
resources to the removal process because
I believe our system must be seen by our
people as firm but fair
we had to sometimes apply pressure on
foreign governments to achieve that
those that succeeded in complying or
proving their status were afforded the
traditional and vital Hospitality that
this country is until now noted for
the government is instead trying to
re-categorize Asylum Seekers as
themselves being criminals before their
cases are even heard
they are using rhetoric which is Extreme
and in implementing their Rwandan scheme
flagrantly ignoring laws not only the
1951 Refugee convention but also other
International agreements and of course
the European convention on human rights
regarding the Rwanda scheme the bill
sets out to diminish the UK Court's
powers to suspend deportation and sets a
dangerous precedent about the way in
which it looks at judicial review
come a noble friend really defend this
Behavior as a lawyer
and when he replies can he please give
us the precise details of that part of
the agreement that obliges the UK to
take Rwandan Asylum Seekers back here
Mao refer him to section 16 of the
memorandum of understanding
changes to the bill were made in the
House of Commons some were made in
deference to extreme demands one was
also made relating to the issue of safe
and legal roots to this country for
Asylum Seekers
we're all aware of those routes which
come from U.N programs indeed I was the
minister responsible for that from
Bosnia in 1996.
we're also aware of special UK programs
from favored countries but noting the
wish of the government to have an annual
limit on such arrivals how can my Noble
friend describe what new Arrangements
might look like the concession in the
Commons does not really give as much to
go on
all UK assembly embassies and consulates
in my view should be a protect should be
a potential application post for entry
where processing can take place that is
the least we should accept
of course the foreign office maintains a
list of safe countries and I accept that
it will be more difficult for those from
such countries to meet the criteria for
Asylum but the opportunities for
applicants must be spread across our
presence wherever in the world it might
be
we need to increase our resources to
deal with cases quickly
but let's go back finally to the channel
and the boats
I was a drafter of the Dublin agreements
when we were in the EU they at least
made it easier to send back Asylum
Seekers within the law since we left the
EU we must rely on bilaterals with our
neighbors and I welcome our discussions
with the French but these need to go
further with Goodwill on both sides
breaking international law my my lords
will certainly not help
also we need to become re-associated
with new EU initiatives to handle the
large number of migrants who try to
enter the Schengen area every year
together we have a better chance of
achieving it my lords there are various
ways in which we can bring about change
to protect lies and our borders at the
same time but that does not include
breaking international law leaving the
European convention on human rights
curtailing the powers of the UK courts
criminalizing innocent victims and
harming as a result our race and
community relations in the UK which a
lot of us have worked so hard over many
years to improve
the
I'm delighted to actually to follow the
speech of Lord kirkhope who was one of
the best speeches I think we've had in
this debate and made it very clear why
this is a bad piece of legislation yes
here here
across Europe
we live in times in which feelings that
so many of us and thought outdated
now appear to be re-emerging
and spreading
Pope Francis spoke those words when he
reflected on the rising tide of
intolerance on our continent
he went on to talk about the feelings of
Suspicion fear contempt and even hatred
towards individuals or groups who are
judged to be different based on their
ethnicity nationality or religion
my lords Britain will face a state of
moral decline if bigotry intolerance and
hatred feel at home in our country
intolerance of people because they are
different will dehumanize our society
recently we have seen some politicians
stoking up intolerance of refugees and
migrants
but the Britain of my lifetime has been
a beacon of Freedom tolerance and
Justice and that's how I want it to
remain
British people actively built links
across communities challenging hatred
welcoming refugees I'm standing up for
those who are victimized and I believe
we see no greater evidence of this
harmony tolerance and Community than the
scenes we have witnessed across the
country these last few days following
the coronation of the king and queen
it's a privilege to sit in this place
but with that privilege goes a duty not
to allow vile ideas to grow and spread
without challenge
the great social reformer Leo abzi MP
was a dear friend once said tolerate
everyone tolerate everything just never
tolerate the intolerant
my lords I believe we must seek to
revolve the issue resolve the issues of
migrants crossing the channel in small
boats and several of us from this house
and the other house raised these matters
when we met French parliamentarians in
July and we urged them to press their
government to work with our government
to end a common approach to see what we
can do but I very much regret that this
piece of populist legislation is no
answer and will solve nothing
rather it WIll Stoke up ill feeling
towards some of the most vulnerable and
desperate people on the planet
refugees
all for a short-term game
and I would ask the architects of this
bill to do one thing
heed the words of the conservative prime
minister Harold McMillan who said
history will judge harshly those who
sacrifice tomorrow for today
my special concern about this bill is
the awful impact it will have upon
unaccompanied migrant children
these Refugee children not only have
need of our protection but they are also
entitled to it because we have ratified
the U.N convention on the rights of the
child
yet across our continent the health and
well-being of unaccompanied Refugee
children is being compromised as I well
know from a report that I did when I was
a member of the Council of Europe
thousands of refugee youngsters are
suffering they're being abused they're
being trafficked they're self-harming
and there's plenty of evidence some are
taking their own lives we must challenge
those using toxic rhetoric about
migration and displaying intolerance and
Prejudice which violates violates basic
human rights political Point scoring
about refugees looks dispely Refugee
migrant children should not be allowed
to deny these children the help that
they need
we should all be concerned about this
bill because the government does not
have a good record in dealing with
unaccompanied migrant children
some four and a half thousand
unaccompany migrant children some as
young as 10 have been placed in hotels
200 have gone missing and have not been
seen again
section 20 of the children act 1989 give
local councils local councils alone The
Authority the statutory authority of
child protection giving them Powers
which includes caring for unaccompanied
migrant children
it does not give these powers to the
home office
my lords there appears to be no legal
basis for placing unaccompanied children
in homes and hotels uh operated by the
home office
now I've twice attempted to discover
which act of parliament has allowed the
government to do this I asked the
minister this last week it's a simple
question I ask again which act of
parliament allows the government to put
these children in hotels
this bill will make the plight of
unaccompanied migrant children even
worse denying them the right to claim
Refuge protection it will make provision
for them to be detained and despite
being youngsters unaccompanied by an
adult it will allow for them to be
removed from this country
my lords is the United Kingdom seriously
going to deport traumatized in need and
unprotected children if we do Shame
Shame Shame on us
my lords there is a legitimate debate to
be had about how the UK manages its
borders
and like other every other Noble payer
in here I have opinions on that too
however but it should I think exclude
those who are already subjected to the
abuse through the heinous crime of
modern slavery
the former prime minister said in the
other place that it has always been
important to separate modern slavery
from immigration status
regrettably this bill brings modern
slavery Into the Heart of the
immigration debate through Clauses 21 to
28 and is using a sledgehammer to crack
a knot
my Lord's the UK has had a proud record
of seeking to protect victims
prevalent modern slavery and prosecute
traffickers the three p's is based on
the UN Palomar protocol
I am pleased to say that the Bella I
introduced in 2013 in Northern Ireland
which passed in 2015 has played its part
it is therefore with great sadness and
dismay that I contemplate the outcome of
this bill on victims across the United
Kingdom and in Northern Ireland
particularly
this bill does not measure up to the
three p's
we are not protecting victims which we
cannot prosecute and the perpetrators of
these crimes without which we cannot
prevent exploitation
the modern slavery strategies of the
devil Nations will go up and smoke
without any consultation and the ability
to care for victims under default
legislation is undermined by this bill
the minister may say that these measures
are necessary to prevent abuse
we heard that last year in the debate on
part 5 of the nationality and borders
act which came into effect only at the
end of January
since then we know that the number of
victims who have received reasonable
grants decision has plummeted
in the last quarter where the home
officer's new guidance applied for two
out of the three months only 49 of
adults received a positive reasonable
grounds decision compared to 87 percent
in 2022
I expect the minister might
say in summing up the number of people
who are referred into the nrm from
immigration immigration detention
the noble Lord the minister in response
to a PQ tabled by the noble Lord Lord
McCall argued that it was individuals
arriving by small boats who are referred
from
detention who are abusing the system
my Lord no one self-refers into the nrm
it is First Responders who refer based
on evidence of exploitation
of course we do not want people abusing
the system
however the number of people who are
referred from detention are small
relative both to the number of people
who come across the channel and to the
number referred into the nrm and the
home office admits that the number of
decision makers has not kept up with
referrals leading to longest delays and
decision making
all of this leads me to conclude that
classes 21 to 20 it are disproportionate
and will negatively impact genuine
victims
I hope the lovable Lord the minister
will update the house on how many
referrals there have been from detention
in the first quarter after the NBA
reforms
finally my Lord I want to come back to
Northern Ireland
the Northern Ireland Human Rights
Commission are of the view that the EU
traffic and directive rights still apply
to victims of Northern Ireland under the
protocol
while the government have argued wrongly
in my opinion that they can deprave
victims of support on public order
crimes under the European convention
against human trafficking in Northern
Ireland victims have another recourse
article 11 of the trafficking directive
I hope the noble Lords the minister will
address this issue as it sets out the
impact of festival for victims in the
devolved Administrations
my lords it is no easy map
to follow so many of your Lordships who
have raised
some difficult and problematic questions
about this bill
can it as it aims prevent and deter
migration particularly by safe and
illegal routes
does it comply with UK law and
international law
some Noble Lords have raised interesting
questions in supporting Lord Paddock in
wanting to see it gone
I agree this is a tough and apparently
uncompromising measure
not only does it oblige the Home
Secretary to detain and remove those
arriving in breach of immigration
control it prohibits a challenge on
human rights or Asylum seeking grounds
to supplies some Modern safe day slavery
protections and bans those subjected
close to from game gaining immigration
or citizenship status in future
it also seeks as your Lordships are
pointed out to avoid the prospect of our
own courts or the European Court of
human rights at Strasbourg holding up
removal
but it is necessary and proportionate on
a number of grounds the functioning of
our democracy under the rule of law laws
made in Westminster
to take account of the change
circumstances since the 1950s and the
new character of immigration into Europe
in general
and for the effect of working of the
Asylum system as so many of your Lords
wish
our laws are made in Parliament our
judges apply them and when necessary
interpret them but ultimately Parliament
not the judicials which must legislate
it does so on the authority on the
authority of the people who vote
and choose a government with a
particular mandate
the Buddhists have made clear on a
number of occasions that they want the
borders controlled and the House of
Commons on this bill has given strong
backing with the majority as has been
said already of around 60 in most
divisions
it is not and I follow some of the Lords
and saying this
it is not in my view for this chamber to
reverse the direction of policy backed
by voters the government and the MPS but
of course there will be room to improve
the matter
my Lord's circumstances and costs have
changed significantly since the
pioneering agreements about which you've
spoken so illuminatingly not only has
international travel risen to mass
proportions but the costs of immigration
have also risen far beyond what could
have imagined in those pioneering days
when Parliament first debated beverages
blueprint for the welfare state
then in 1943 the premise was the benefit
and the benefit system would depend on
individual contribution
each individual paid a contribution and
benefit was linked to it although there
was discretionary provision for
exceptional assistance
by 1951 the year of the convention
potential deviation from the
contributory principle
even over such a thing as a qualifying
period for old age pension was a most
serious matter of debate
today the system is significantly
different
it's more expensive and it's far more
reliant on tax funding
with higher expectations for social
security health care and education
as families struggle to pay the bills it
is right to tackle the rising costs of
illegal migration which we are all
paying through an increased tax base for
that and other things and I needn't
remind your Lordships that the UK is now
at its almost highest tax
extraction I would say since the Second
World War
and it this problem is not a UK problem
alone the small boats may be but not the
general problem of people wanting to
settle in Western European countries
already as husband mentioned rule 39 of
the European court rules are being
reconsidered and reviewed with
representations from a number of member
states
I'm afraid that the though I wish the
government well with its transfer
Arrangements
there is less of an appetite for
transfer or return agreements than may
have existed 20 years ago
immigration has moved center stage in
all our neighboring countries in France
president's president president macron's
immigration Bill is having a not very
happy reception from left and right with
demonstrations in the streets
earlier this month the Italian foreign
minister canceled a trip to Paris
because the French interior Minister had
said
the Italian Prime Minister was incapable
of controlling migration
and that was hardly months after the
dust settled on the diversion by Italy
of a ship a humanitarian ship carrying
300 refugees to France
those of us who want and I am one of
them safe and legal Asylum system for
people fleeing persecution and danger to
life and an immigration system which
supports the UK's economic needs
recognize we must manage Booth
effectively
removing illegal migrants from this
country while their applications are
processed may sound drastic
but if the alternative is to build them
into local hotels and disused Barracks
there is a danger of undermining social
cohesion
and the rule of law
the laws of this country matter
they are and have for centuries been
fair and welcoming to those who flee
persecution in their homelands
generous to the many thousands including
myself
who came to this country to take
advantage of its unparalleled
opportunities
Futures now want their borders
controlled
I support this bill because it is
necessary to tackle a particular problem
because the UK like its fellow European
countries must recognize the political
imperative and because it is a duty on
those responsible for fiscal and
economic Affairs to control expenditure
but above all I support it because the
laws which govern this country should
protect the Liberties of all its people
be fair and proportionate and have the
support of the people in whose name the
law is made
Chicago
uh my lords if I may well it was one of
the few conversations and speaking so
late he does enable me to try and
respond to some of the points made in
this uh fascinating but I think worrying
debate
um over the last few hours uh and Noble
or Society is not here but I did want to
come back to the challenge he raised
right at the beginning which when he
said those who are opposed to the bill
are they not concerned about the plight
of these poor people coming over at
perilous cost often to their lives in
these small boats having been exploited
by this international criminal accounts
of course my lords we are concerned
about those people but my lords whether
this bill is the right way to deal with
the issue I have very severe doubts now
no blood Forsyth also challenged us to
come up with a coherent alternative
which I think my Lord is somewhat
disingenuous given the skepticism which
so many of us have about whether this
bill will actually achieve its stated
intentions but I did think by Lords that
the um December the 9th debate
the Archbishop the most
no it's not it's the most
yes indeed the most forever in primary
Prime the most reverent primate really
laid it out uh my Lord
um a rigorous approach to combating
Smugglers why don't we hear more about
that from the government
the provision of safe and legal ways for
people to get here and to receive
assessment and where appropriate
protection and my lords he argued for an
update to the 1951 Refugee convention to
meet modern circumstances that seems to
me International cooperation based on
human rights is a much more effective
way to develop a plan to deal with these
issues
uh my Lord
um the second point I really wanted to
make is a comeback to one made again
right at the start by the noble and
learned it Lord Etherton who referred to
the fact that under immigration rules
there is no Asylum Visa route for an
individual Refugee to enter the UK and
claim Asylum that means that unless a
person is within one of the four
resettlement schemes or Asylum is sought
by someone already legally present in
the UK the refugees arrival in an entry
to the UK will inevitably be illegal as
he said this bill is not therefore a
small boat Bill the provisions of the
bill will affect all who seek refugees
status in this country and are entitled
to the protection of the 1951 convention
the third point I'd make my laws is
really to refer to the extraordinary
intervention by the Home Secretary this
morning and seeking to tell this house
what she considers our duty to be I
actually think my lords this house is
well able to make up its own mind on
that but for me upholding the rule of
law and international law obligations
preventing the unfettered power being
given to the Home Secretary in this bill
questioning the retrospective nature
some of the Bill's provisions and
seeking to retain the protections
contained in the modern slavery act and
matters which should weigh rather more
heavily in our deliberations than the
home secretary's crude attempt to
distract from our own lamentable
performance by indulging in dog whistle
politics of the worst kind
Milo's my fourth point is really to
question the minister on the
government's assertions in relation to
Modern slavery that the bill is needed
to prevent people from gaming the system
the leading modern slavery charity
Hestia who supported over 2 700 victims
in London last year has seen no evidence
to suggest the government's modern
slavery process is being exploited by
individuals seeking asylum in the UK
this is backed up by a number of other
modern slavery Charities who've written
to us over the last few days leaves and
I mean if you just look at what
Nottingham University human trafficking
UK have said the victims of modern
slavery may not know they've entered the
UK legally traffickers made deliberately
withhold information and documentation
as a means of control and may have
offered to arrange travel on behalf of
those they are planning to exploit it's
a potential victims therefore may be
unaware of their status or need for
entry documentation believing
traffickers have erased this for them
now the minister earlier spoke of the
generosity of British people number of
noble Lords are referred to it well I
agree and I suspect that generosity
would extend to wanting to protect the
protections that we have in the modern
slavery act now rightly my lords the
government took great credit
internationally
for the provisions of the 2015
legislation and I applaud them for it
now they are ruining that throwing it
away recklessly and with it the
protections for some of the most
vulnerable people my Lord if I could
just stand by commenting on Lord
paddock's Amendment which he spoke to
with such force uh it's always
interesting I have to say that liberal
Democrats um have always questioned the
legitimacy of this chamber and it's
interesting my lords that they seem to
rather changed their minds and feel it's
legitimate for us to reject a bills that
is not what we do we have the ability to
scrutinize this wretched Bill thoroughly
and I hope he will do so yeah I
apologize for Noble Lord for being
little premature uh my lords um one of
the Striking things about this very
interesting debate is that Noble Lords
on all sides of the chamber have spoken
in many cases as if they were proceeding
from a sort of fundamental principle of
great importance to them uh for some it
was the vision of what our country is uh
for others um it was a universal
principle of humanitarianism uh for
others again it might have been a
commitment to internationalism as a
means of resolving uh problems and and
there were others of course
um my fundamental starting point is is
more mundane it is the international
legal principle that no country is
obliged to admit foreign Nationals and
if they do so they may impose conditions
on that entry now of course we in this
country mitigate that right our right to
refuse to admit foreign Nationals
um in ways that we have chosen to do
over the past for example when we were
members of the European Union we gave
free access to the country to citizens
of EU member states another way in which
we have a bridge that International
right is by entering of course into the
refugee convention and inevitably these
sorts of Arrangements involve some sort
of international agreement and so can be
categorized as falling under the The
Heading of international law I'm not of
course a lawyer nor making a legal point
but we need as in my view to take
account as my Noble my just disappeared
Noble friend lord balth said of the
circumstances in which we entered into
those arrangements and whether those
circumstances continue to apply because
we have in my view a degree of
flexibility about how we apply them in
the light of changing circumstances the
circumstances in which we entered the
refugee convention
contemplated broadly the care of often
large numbers of people displaced by War
and other catastrophes usually in
adjacent countries and on a temporary
basis until they could return safely to
their home
how is it and I think a lot of people
would ask this question how is it that
by means of the same convention we are
having a debate this evening about
transcontinental travel
facilitated by profitable travel
agencies run as a business they may be
criminal Enterprises but they are
profitable travel agencies run as a
business with a view to permanent
settlement this is no a very long way
indeed from where we started now some
people may say well of course the world
has changed since we entered the
convention and this is what the world is
like now and we should share our burden
and I fully accept arguments that say
that it is right that Britain as a
leading international power should share
burdens and we there are ways in which
we can share burdens by doing things for
people who are displaced into countries
and not necessarily in this by coming to
this country but helping them in the
places where they are displaced and it
could be said that we could do more on
that front
we then come I can't resist saying this
to references to the European convention
on human rights I find it very hard in
uh from Noble many noble Lords to accept
comments about the European convention
on human rights
when we so lightly pass over the fact
that the rights of the people of our own
people in Northern Ireland to a say in
the laws they live under is Abridged by
the Northern Ireland protocol and by the
uh the Windsor framework that has
followed it but but but when it when it
suits us we're all we're all for the
European convention on human rights but
we're willing to Blink it uh when it
doesn't and I think there is a degree of
of double-sidedness on that if I may
call that
now I do have some concerns it's not all
good news for my Noble friend on the
front bench I do have some concerns
about the bill in particular the fact
which has been alluded to glancingly by
some Noble Lords that it catches
deliberately captures some British
citizens within its scope it is possible
in fact to be a British Citizen and
still be an illegal migrant under this
bill and denied access to British
citizenship as a result of being an
illegal migrant and that is because the
drafters of the bill I assume from the
home office have as they have so often
in the past deliberately conflated the
two concepts of naturalization and
registration they have treated them
separately in the bill in separate
Clauses but they have imposed the same
penalties and the same process and it
will not be the first time that I've
reminded Noble Lords that the two two
things are entirely different
naturalization is a concession whereby
the British government gives citizenship
to people of foreign nationality
registration a process I believe
introduced by the post-war labor
government is a process whereby the
British State acknowledges an existing
right to British citizenship which has
been difficult to establish either
through the vagueness of circumstances
or the want of proper documentation it
is akin to the sort of blunders we fell
into that led to the scandal of the
Windrush problem now I do believe that
the bill needs to be amended looked at
very carefully to ensure that those who
are entitled to British citizenship by
way of registration are not denied those
rights because they arrive in the
country irregularly and I'll be coming
back I hope no other Noble Lords will be
coming back to this when we reach report
committing
my Lord's eye declare my interest as an
immigrant
as a proud immigrant this country has
given me so many opportunities
to build from scratch a consumer brand
Cobra beer loved by this country a
household name in the UK
to be the youngest University Chancellor
in this country from 2005 to 2010 at the
University of West London to be the
first indian-born Chancellor for Russell
group University in this country the
third largest university the University
of Birmingham to join this house
as one of its three youngest peers 17
years ago
to be the first zoroastrian Parsi to sit
in the history of this house
and I hail from the smallest minority
community in the world the zarastrian
parsis there are just one hundred
thousand of us in the world
and we fled from Iran
Persia in those days to escape religious
persecution
we went to India and over the centuries
I'm proud to say that per capita of
achievement is probably one of the most
successful communities in the world and
that's because good immigration has
always worked the 14 of immigrants in
this country contribute so much to make
sure that this country with one percent
of the world's population is still the
sixth largest economy in the world and
the immigrants in this country and the
children of immigrants are reaching the
very top and no better example than our
prime minister Rishi sunak
the noble Lord the minister started the
debate by saying that the purpose of the
illegal migration bill is to prevent and
deter unlawful migration in particular
Migration by unsafe and illegal Roots by
requiring the removal from the UK
and yet my lords this bill as we've
heard from so many noble laws today
creates a hostile image of immigration
I would say even more so than Theresa
May when she was Home Secretary and then
prime minister when she created a
hostile approach and image of
immigration from 2010 to
2019. for example in 2012 she removed
the two-year post-graduation work visa
for international students which I
spearheaded in
2007-2008 and Boris Johnson brought it
back to start again in 2021
this bill is focusing on the boats this
bill is focusing on one of the five
pledges of the Prime Minister we all
want the boats to stop it's not that's
not the question it's how we do it that
matters not in an inhuman way not in a
way that breaches international law not
in a way that breaches International
commitments The Bar Council considers
that the bill as currently drafted is
incompatible with the principles which
underlie the rule of law
not in a way that removes this country's
centuries-owned reputation for fairness
and Justice which is respected around
the world
so this bill is meant to be a deterrent
but let's put this in perspective the 45
000 people who came across in those
boats
last year make up less than 10 percent
of the net migration of 500 000 people
into this country and it is a fear of
migration that is created it is a fear
that led to David Cameron Theresa May
wanting to bring it down to the tens of
thousands where are we in the tens of
thousands it's five hundred thousand
it's the fear of immigration created for
example by Angela Merkel when she said
she would allow one million refugees to
settle in Germany in 2015 at the height
of the Syrian crisis and whether we like
it or not that fear played a major part
in the brexit vote turning out the way
that it did
and yet look at today on the 23rd of
February this year a study brought out
by King's College London
the UK public have among the most
positive attitudes to immigration
according to the study that ranks the
country at the top of an international
league table as the most accepting of
new arrivals so where is this will of
the people that's the will of the people
this is the latest study that's come out
and would the Nobel Lord the minister
please explain to me why are
international students included in the
net migration figures International
students have now reached a record high
of 680 000 and this is primarily because
of the two-year post graduation work
visa being brought in they are not
immigrants on the whole they return to
their countries in fact if you look at
the immigration figures the highest
number of students higher than people
who come to work and it's because the UN
says one year you have to categorize
people as as immigrants even a one-year
master's degree means an international
student is categorized as an immigrant
other countries exclude them from their
net migration figures why is the
government making a road for its own
back
why are international students being
used in this way is it being used to
create a fear of migration is it being
used to create a hostile approach to
immigration I just don't understand it
my Lord I I'm like a stock record please
because the noble law the minister in
his winding up address this point and as
co-chair of the old party parliamentary
group on International students and
president for the UK Council for
international student affairs
International students bring in 30
billion pounds into this country and are
one of our strongest elements of
stockpile to conclude my lords of course
we want to address the Asylum claims 108
38 000 backlog is unacceptable we need
to process them quicker of course we
need to address tackle and stop the
illegal immigration in this awful
dangerous sadly tragic small boats
crossing the channel but let us never
take for granted the good immigration
that has benefited this country for
which we should always be grateful and
always appreciate because it is the good
immigration that is made Great Britain
Great
my lords it is a privilege to speak
following the noble Lord Lord lamaria
and and particularly on this issue of
illegal migration which Cuts right to
the core of who we are as a nation now
to use my time to ask three questions
first will the stated objective of this
bill be achieved
second do we have the right Target in
our sights
and third are there things that could be
done to ensure the new system reflects
the values of our nation
so first for the stated objective of
this bill be achieved my lords as we've
heard over and over again the purpose of
this bill is to prevent and deter
unlawful migration and in particular
Migration by unsafe and illegal roots
the fact that that bill has very similar
objectives to the previous one requires
us to take a hard look at what we are
doing and ask ourselves whether it will
be effective
my lords I agree with the premise as do
most of us in this house of both last
year's Bill and this year's illegal
migration bill that we must take back
control of our borders and break the
business model of people smuggling
Networks
however my concern is whether a focus on
deterrence will in fact achieve these
objectives
the government itself has admitted that
the evidence of the efficacy of
deterrence measures is limited
so presuming that this legislation has
only limited efficacy and that channel
Crossings continue in some form or
another after this bill has been passed
I asked my Noble friend the minister to
outline how his Majesty's government
intends to implement the mass Detention
of irregular arrivals that will continue
and how they will support those who are
not able to be removed after 28 days of
detention because of a lack of returns
agreement
in international terms we are taking an
unorthodox approach to our Asylum system
it is clear that we are not confident
this approach will be effective so I ask
my Noble friend the minister whether he
would include a review mechanism in this
bill so that Parliament has a chance to
evaluate the success of this novel
approach and whether if it proves to be
ineffective to disapply it
the second question I want to raise is
whether we have the right Target in our
sites with this piece of legislation our
sites are firmly set on the Asylum
seeker and the trafficked and not the
trafficker
if we were to put as much energy into
targeting the real criminals into
imprisoning the criminal gangs we would
be standing on firmer ground
it is not illegal to cross a border and
claim Asylum this is a protection set
out in the refugee Convention of 1951 it
is us who is choosing to make it illegal
over 70 of the people who come by these
routes are granted Asylum by our own
system and our own definitions
but we are also dismantling much of the
modern day slavery legislation by going
after those being trafficked rather than
the traffickers
the removal and exclusion from support
of those victims who've been exploited
in the UK will drive victims underground
making them less likely to come forward
this will not only hinder victims
recovery but damage the chances for
prosecutions without support and if
removed to another country most victims
will be unable to cooperate with
investigations
I believe that this house will want to
pick up the Amendments laid by the right
honorable Ian Duncan Smith and Theresa
May in the other place
but my lords I'm also wanting to engage
constructively with this bill so I ask
whether there are things that could be
done to ensure the new system reflects
the values of our nation
we have always been a place that
welcomes those who are genuinely in need
our commitment to the refugee is founded
on our Christian Heritage
there has been much said during the
passage of this bill about safe and
legal roots in this chamber during the
passing of the nationality and borders
bill I supported an amendment that would
make provision for ten thousand to come
to the UK through safe and legal routes
as a way of ensuring we created the
infrastructure that would care for
people properly rather than as lurching
from one emergency situation to another
the government has indicated it is
willing to do this but there are some
factors that it would be worth us
exploring together as part of this
we will need assurance that these safe
and legal routes will be set up to
welcome those who need protection
whatever country they come from and not
just country specific schemes be that
Afghanistan Yemen and most recently
Sudan
and we need to work with the grain of
local communities and not against them
a recent study for more in common showed
that when Community sponsorship of
refugees is an option a majority of
people are in favor of accepting more
refugees into the UK
therefore can I encourage the minister
to explore safe routes that include
schemes like homes for Ukraine that
would save the taxpayer Millions while
also allowing refugees to integrate into
British Society
and finally as we've also heard from
others tonight this is all part of a
much bigger picture that will only be
resolved as we reach for diplomatic
Solutions
ultimately stopping Channel Crossings
and taking back control of our borders
can only be achieved through diplomacy
not through domestic legislation
therefore I urge the government to
negotiate a returns agreement with
France and the European Union and to
lead the way in instigating a global
solidarity pact with like-minded states
that would update the international
Refugee system and make it fit for the
21st century
I look forward to working as a house to
support the government to achieve their
stated objective of stopping the boats
but doing so in a way that balances
control with compassion
I believe we can find a way to put
people's Smugglers out of business and
end the exploitation of vulnerable
people whilst also ensuring that this
new chapter in the story of the United
Kingdom is founded on International
responsibility and human dignity
your lordship's house will have an
opportunity to scrutinize this very
large and complex Bill and its details
so I will focus uh on general principles
perversely although I think this bill is
politically constitutionally and morally
and imperative I agree with the comments
of the noble Lord palik and the noble
Lord green of deadington because within
the wider context it is only because we
have a failed and dysfunctional legal
migration regime that such a bill is
necessary notwithstanding the
geopolitical refugee crisis affecting
the rich world
the British people did not vote to Take
Back Control of our borders in 2016 for
any government to preside over more than
500 000 net migration figures each year
but for special pleading from big
business for more cheap foreign labor
for five million people on how to work
benefits 1.9 billion pound per week
spent in Social benefits for working age
people for welfare dependency and the
stalling of social mobility and
productivity and for pay and training
for UK citizens to be reduced over time
and actually I predicted this as Member
of Parliament for Peterborough in 2006
in the wake of the European Union free
movement directive I made it clear that
there would be serious ramifications on
the delivery of public services and for
that I was met by Hyperbole and
allegations of racism xenophobia and
being a little Englander but if even
Tony Blair conceded that that piece of
legislation was in error
I would rather not support this bill
um and I do agree that as other speakers
have said the British people are decent
they are fair they are compassionate and
welcoming you only need to look at the
figures that the un's HCR have produced
it showed that we're the second most
welcoming country in Europe for refugees
who doesn't believe uh that it takes
great courage to cross continents to
seek a better life for and a better
future for our families and children but
it is naive and irresponsible to ignore
Our obligation to propose Solutions
based on real world experience
responsible government is about
difficult choices and competing
interests and that's why the liberal
Democrats fatal motion is I'm afraid
both irresponsible and an abdication of
our duty to respond to legitimate public
concerns about this growing migration
crisis
it's naive and foolhardy too not to
recognize that of course people
traffickers will abuse and exploit the
loopholes around modern slavery and I
have to say respectfully to my former
colleague the former prime minister
Theresa May she perhaps should have a
word with the Home Secretary who
presided over the drafting of the modern
slavery bill in 2015 because to ignore
the ramifications and those
exploitations I think is wrong that said
I I think that the Amendments that she's
proposed and other Noble Lords have
proposed are certainly worth looking at
I also um think that and it has to be
said that this house has no mandate to
block or wreck this bill whatsoever it
is a manifestal commitment from the 2019
general election it is popular and has
public support
um and was passed by a significant
majority in the other place
I agree with the White River and
prelates but we need to legislate with
compassion but those of us who support
the bill are no less caring or
empathetic to the real world horrors of
modern slavery and people trafficking
and I have to say frankly as an Anglican
I find it dispiriting that the leaders
of my own church who were silent over
the impact of 20 years of uncontrolled
immigration
should seek to mischaracterize those of
us who have the courage to support these
bold measures as morally deficient that
is not the case
my penultimate point is this
much talk has been made of breaking
international law
we should not regard supernational legal
entities and their obligations as
shibboleths and Theological tablets
never to be questioned it may be unusual
but our dualist treaty regime in this
country preserves the rights and duties
of legislators against an overmighty
executive and a potentially politicized
Judiciary and this house is part of that
durable and well understood
constitutional settlement
and after all our first duty is the
safety of our own citizens
of whatever background
in conclusion what we have heard today
is much criticism exaggeration outrage
and some intemperate language cries of
shame but very few if any real workable
Alternatives it is a perfectly Noble
Viewpoint to believe in open borders
Mass migration to a country with a
population density the highest in Europe
a housing crisis infrastructure
pressures and a debt Mountain but let's
be honest about it
what does that policy really mean the
shame will be to do nothing to give
sustenance to the evil people
traffickers to betray the British people
to betray those who came here legally
and and hope it will all go away well it
won't
I welcome this bill I support this bill
and I wish ministers well in its
possibly quite difficult journey through
this house
my Lord's it's been a long day and I
won't detain the house too long before
the winding UPS features
however opportunities to wholeheartedly
support the government on its
legislation arise perhaps less often
than I would ideally wish
and when I do so that the government's
developed a distressing habit of
visiting or spiking the legislation
afterwards however I'm very confident it
won't happen on this occasion so I do
want to take this opportunity to speak
strongly in support of this this
business my Lord's the basic principle
we must not forget is that a democratic
nation state such that ours has and
should have the right to control its
borders and determine who gets to live
here and on what terms until quite
recently this would have been an
uncontroversial statement and in my
experience it still is the further one
gets from London sw1 still in recent
years this country did lose that right
as regards to EU citizens and the
general principle has been subject to
sustained attack from those who perhaps
don't always see the point of
international borders at all and the
result of all this has been the
difficulty the government faces in
enforcing its immigration laws and in
recent years is very high and
unsustainable levels of legal migration
now as my Noble friend Lord Moreland
pointed out that basic principle the
right to control borders is of course
shaped by the many commitments we've
taken on our membership of the echr the
refugee convention and much else our own
suas Ponte commitments on Modern slavery
but all these commitments must indeed
can only be implemented in a way that is
in accordance with practical reality
governments don't have the luxury of
being content with just words they must
deal in reality not in Concepts and one
obvious reality is that tens perhaps
hundreds of millions of people could
establish an asylum claim if they could
get to this country and many want to
so if we acquiesce in illegal arrivals
the numbers will continue to grow if we
open new legal routes they will be
quickly overwhelmed and we will be back
to the illegal ones it is simply not
possible to make what is amounted to an
open unlimited offer to anyone who can
get here and that's why this bill is
necessary and why if it becomes law no
one who arrives in this country
illegally with some reasonable but
limited exceptions will be allowed to
stay here that principle contrary to
what's been said by Southern overlords
tonight that specific principle is
strongly supported in this country in
the yougov polling from March shows that
supported by an absolute majority of
public opinion
now we're told by some we've heard today
that to enshrine these principles in a
bill is in some way and I use words that
have been used
during the day is in some way shameful
inhuman immoral or even evil now I
disagree with that so they actually
rather resent it
it is with the greatest trepidation that
I debate morality with the the high
prelates of the the church but but I
can't agree that we're not living up to
our moral responsibility if some of us
in this Fallen World Fallen world come
to different judgments about the
implications of the words of Jesus in
Matthew 25.
all we're told by others on bench stops
it that because everyone who gets to
these Shores has a potentially huge
contribution to make to this country it
is immoral and self-defeating to turn
them away
of course I agree that every person who
comes here has the same potential as
every other human being I don't think
any of us believe that Asylum Seekers
are bad people there are people doing
the best for themselves and their
families but everyone who gets here
imposes a burden as well as makes
contribution and some communities it is
true to say have integrated into British
society and life better than others it
is the job of the government and of the
British people to decide where the line
should be drawn and this bill draws one
element of it there's nothing immoral in
that or if you think there is you must
think it's immoral for British
governments to pay proper attention to
the views of their own citizens
we've also heard that the Right Way
Forward is to renegotiate the
international framework covering
refugees that's certainly desirable but
anyone who thinks it could be done in
the short term or perhaps at all on
terms that we would wish to see is
kidding themselves I'm afraid
the same is true of those who think
spending vast sums on development or a
mitigating so-called climate migration
is going to do anything to deal with the
real problem we now face now
my Lord's all the arguments against this
bill are I'm sure based on deep
reflection and conviction but in the end
I can't think that they really deal with
the real world problem
the real world choice that faces this
government is simple it's to choose to
put in place an organized set of
Provisions for a limited number of
genuine refugees in numbers that this
country can cope with and make clear
that others will not be able to stay or
is to live with the current and
worsening situation and open-ended but
de facto constrained Arrangements
Refugee arrivals constrained not by any
rational arrangements or judgments but
by the Readiness of those poor traffic
people to travel to pay to deal with
criminals and bear terrible risks
my laws there will certainly be
important technical improvements
improvements we can make to this bill
this house should certainly give it
proper scrutiny but none of that removes
the real need for the fundamental
principles behind this bill I urge the
government not to be deterred by the
arguments they've heard today but to
push on with the bill and strain all the
sinews of the state to deliver on it
when it becomes lost
yeah my lords I want to thank the host
for allowing me to speak in the gap
only days ago the king made solemn
commitments to Justice to equity and to
Mercy
and here we are dismissing those values
in this bill
I find it repugnant
to hear this Furious use of Market Force
values
as an argument
for
this bill
that the need to crush traffickers
the supply side involves having to crush
demand
as though the demand were not human
beings with needs often people who've
been persecuted people who've watched
other members of their family being
slaughtered
who have suffered torture themselves who
witnessed the women in their family
being raped
but we have to crush demand
so to devise a scheme as cruel and as
vicious as possible is necessary
to deflect people from Crossing
we have to devise a scheme that has no
due process which has been one of the
fundamentals in our rule of law
and we're going to lump together those
who are Asylum Seekers with possibly
those amongst them who might be simply
here to better themselves which are Lord
Frost had just talked about but describe
those people as being Asylum Seekers the
conflation between those who might be
coming for economic reasons and those
who are Asylum Seekers fleeing
persecution
is one of the problems about this bill
I really wanted to speak to the fact
that this bill is having a huge impact
on our Global reputation
I am the director of an Institute for
the international Bar Association and so
I traveled to conferences uh regularly I
was only last week at the UN in New York
and judges and lawyers
talk to me about their concerns about
what is happening around issues of law
in our country they say what's happening
to Britain the prison has led the world
in championing the rule of law that was
the flagship nation in creating the
rules-based order after World War II
that drafted the the European convention
on human rights was key to so many
conventions including the refugee
convention and created in fact the the
the the model for the modern slavery
legislation that's being taken up in
other countries too
we've always looked to Britain they say
as a beacon
that we've all been persuading our
countries to follow
but what's happening
and so we're putting at risk that
reputation our statute stature in the
world will be greatly damaged by bills
like this in our dismissal of our treaty
obligations our commitment to
international law
and the fear that is expressed is that
Britain by showing a reckless disregard
for law will in fact bring about the
collapse of that rules-based system
because other countries authoritarianism
is growing as we know in so many places
will be only too happy to follow suit
and I remind us all of the law of
unintended consequences the once you
start unraveling these things like for
example rule 39 which allows has allowed
us to we've used ourselves since the
Year 2005 where you we've used only last
year in relation to Russia's invasion of
Ukraine
and it will be used as evidence that
they have failed to comply with it
when we come to bring people like Putin
before International courts
for war crimes so please don't unravel
law which has been so important in
creating a Unity across the globe which
has been so vital in in securing Justice
and in our attempts to secure Peace So I
advocate what the Archbishop has
advocated which is that we actually
cling to those International
obligations and sets of principles that
we make use of them and engage with
other countries to try and meet the
challenges here and we set up proper
Swift systems to determine who are
Asylum Seekers and who are not and I
hope this bill will be amended out of
existence because it is unworkable it's
unlawful and it is immoral I say to all
of you and we have to ask ourselves is
this what we're standing for in the
world
opportunity to speak in the Gap and it's
an honor to follow Noble baroness
um lady Kennedy once again I will focus
my comments on pregnant migrant women
and a lot has been said already by Lord
Cashman baroness Lister right Reverend
uh Bishop of Gloucester baronessog and
baroness Brinton and many others
like them I am Gravely concerned about
the safety of pregnant women new mothers
and their babies
the legislation its current form may
result in them being detained
indefinitely and being taken out of the
UK
pregnant women and new mothers are
amongst the most vulnerable in society
and we have a duty to safeguard them
we therefore
that we therefore need to provide them
the right nutrition the right Health
Care
the right physical and mental health and
monitoring to detect problems
and making them stay in overcrowded
centers can risk in increase the risk in
infectious disease
result in poor Mental Health
we they cannot be provided the Right
Care at the right time
why can't these small numbers of
pregnant migrant women be housed in the
community I say that because this
morning the minister mentioned that most
illegal migrants are men also
um what risks can these pregnant women
pose in society if I remember rightly
this morning it was mentioned that the
measures in this bill are needed to keep
us safe the government already have a
terrible record when it comes to
pregnant women who are detained for
example women in prison have up to seven
times a higher probability of suffering
still birth than in the general
population
women who were returning from abroad
during the covered pandemic were put at
risk when the government made them stay
in quarantine hotels I want to remind
this house of what happened to Amina
Bibi when she returned from Pakistan she
was in a quarantine Hotel she asked for
help and someone decided that she'd gone
to a hospital too many times and at 34
weeks she lost her baby nearly bled to
death and was in intensive care
as my lords will be aware there has been
a lot of publicity on maternity
disparities and I want to declare an
interest as the CEO of Muslim women's
Network UK and officer of the appg on
Muslim women we produce a report on
maternity disparities and that report
like many other maternity reports and
the statistics on maternity care show
one thing very clearly that minoritized
women and their babies have a higher
mortality rate these women are more
likely to have a miscarriage women born
outside of the UK are more likely to
have worse maternity outcomes now the
government has pledged to address these
maternity inequalities so then how can
on one hand the government then say it
will reduce harm for pregnant women
while on the other hand bringing
legislation that will create a system
that will cause harm to pregnant women
and their babies
it is cruel heartless and Humane so Lord
fost I am using those words again and I
don't apologize for them the medical and
maternity experts all state that the
government proposals are putting
pregnant women and their babies at risk
of physical and mental harm among them
are all College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists the war quality of
midwives doctors of the world maternity
action and many more my lords this
disregard of expert opinion and of
safeguarding is shameful
timely safe and adequate maternity care
can only be received if pregnant women
were living in the community
why Nova Lord farmer mentioned earlier
that the UK could become a magnet for
pregnant women I respectfully and
strongly disagree with that point so
therefore I urge the government to do
the right thing and not to detain
pregnant women
my lords the house will forgive me for
not name checking individual Noble Lords
I've heard it said a number of times of
this bill this is not who we are as a
nation nor is it how I used to think of
the conservative party I rarely agreed
with them but I respected them
I looked to the government to lead not
Stoke up both Prejudice and fear
these are human beings who in very very
large part are fleeing conflict torture
persecution and danger human beings as
we are but I see no attempt to walk in
their shoes to see each as an individual
with his own character and history each
child as a child and many of them
vulnerable
the minister wrote to peers saying I
quote as you will know over 45
000 people illegally crossed the channel
in small boats last year abusing our
laws and Asylum protections no I don't
know 45
000 people did that I do know this is
victim blaming and I want to acknowledge
the refugees welcome and other support
groups and individuals who see Asylum
Seekers as people in need of support
I know this bill is immoral it's
presented as moral we must save people
from the dangers of the channel well of
course but even if it will what about
the dangers from which Asylum Seekers
are escaping
the very presentation of some so-called
safe countries designated in the bill as
safe for men or women only indicates the
government does know the human rights
problems but there are no nuances no
caveats
safe and legal roots are not as
suggested irrelevant they should be the
precursor to legislation
the bill is misconceived it won't act as
a deterrent to Asylum Seekers so it
won't deter the traffickers it will
create a new market for Smugglers among
people removed to countries which are
not appropriate
the modern slavery act should be
strengthened not weakened
in January changes were introduced to
address false slavery claims by bringing
into Force the nationality and borders
act it is far too soon to assess those
changes
allowing a victim to remain in the UK
just so long as is necessary for a
prosecution says a good deal about the
government's refusal against
professional opinion to understand that
few victims are able to produce a
complete statement without considerable
support often over a long period
trauma-informed
Noble Lords have spoken of giving
traffickers another tool go to the
police and you'll be removed from the UK
why cast Asylum Seekers as the
wrongdoers over stairs who had visas
know they have no right to be here they
outnumber Asylum Seekers by many times
of course we've heard a lot about total
migration numbers
I'm grateful to for the mention of the
report by the select committee which I'm
lucky enough to chair as the way the
government should go on immigration
the government used to be good at soft
power
what a clever strategy to seek to load
things on our nearest European neighbors
this refusal to acknowledge the global
situation to address what might truly be
a fair share is the very opposite of
seeking Global cooperation and it's more
than a closed door it's drawing up the
port colors
there's deep concern about the impact on
the land border between Northern Ireland
and the Republic of Ireland it's not
apparent that the government considered
or consulted on this
and how is this bill perceived by
minority communities in the UK let's not
forget Community cohesion and
integration it's clear that the benefits
of diversity pass the government by
the bill is illegal and the house will
as always be glad of its lawyers
just take its retrospective effect legal
certainty requires Clarity at the
relevant time which is not in this case
the 7th of March 2023 with Parliament at
that point being taken for granted
it's a central tenet of the rule of law
the court of appeal called it a
requirement of good Administration by
which public bodies ought to deal
straightforwardly and consistently with
the public
the minister says the section 19
position is legally untested I thought
the government was rather critical of
people running off to the courts to test
legality and of the Court's treading
where the government thinks they
shouldn't
I confess there's a good deal about the
bill that puzzles me and rely on a writ
of habeas corpus which is about the
lawfulness of detention
when the legislation makes the detention
legal
and that the party that claimed to be
good housekeepers does not focus first
of all on the efficiency of the home
office
detention used as instant punishment
before any infringement is established
legal Avenues blocked and the courts
blocked from getting on with their job
to a proper timetable and what happened
to necessity and proportionality
I could almost say thank goodness the
bill will be unworkable
but for what it will mean for so many
children and adults not even as good as
having a life on hold driven towards
exploitation not protected from it
driven to the underground economy
how much will we know of this presumably
the numbers won't appear in the home
office applications backlog because the
claims will be inadmissible and so not
counted
immoral misconceived illegal
it's obviously not possible to cover
every Point made in a few minutes as the
many organizations who've briefed us so
extensively will realize and to whom
will continue to look at later stages
fundamentally unacceptable bill doesn't
become acceptable by amending it at the
edges
the parliament Act is a red herring even
if there were time to Ram the same bill
through it's not that straightforward
there would be no time for
implementation before the next election
and to those who say that opponents of
the bill should be setting out their
policy I'm sure they would have said in
response to speeches setting up policy
that this wasn't the time especially
given the bills short and long titles
by the way our policy is not to admit
everyone like the most reverent Prime
that my Noble friend did not say we
would
finally
finally perhaps the most egregious
aspect of the bill
it deprives people of Hope and hope is
so precious
my Lord's my own default mode is to look
for compromise and consensus but I can't
do so here I feel contaminated by this
bill
[Applause]
uh my lords I too won't be attempting to
name check everyone who's spoken in this
debate it's been a fascinating but a
worrying debate and I'd like to thank
all the many briefing organizations that
have said briefings which are many of
which have been referred to during the
debate
my Lord's the head note for
understanding this bill is that is that
it attacks the ability of people to come
to the UK irregularly and claim Asylum
or make human rights claims it shuts
them out and imposes a duty of removal
in the absence of agreements of wrong
removal or readmission to their home or
third countries the people will remain
in the UK without status either in
detention potentially for an indefinite
period of time or supported at public
expense because they are unable to work
it manufactures are growing and
potentially permanent population of
people in the UK who are for all
practical purposes
unremovable and who are a burden on the
public purse
it is in effect it is ineffective and it
breaches International treaty
commitments the bill contains a number
of things that disrupt the established
relationship between the government and
the courts for example it advises the
ability to seek Liberty from being
unlawfully detained it also removes
protection from people who are victims
of trafficking in order that they may be
treated as irregular arrival arrivals as
well
in the media you will see that the
motivation for this bill is the problem
created by people crossing the English
Channel in small boats but in reality
the bill affects all people arriving
irregularly it also extends human rights
claims made by EU citizens in the UK and
that can affect their family life and
their private life rights I think this
is a point which was made by the noble
Lord Lord Atherton
I believe this will create additional
problems in our relationships with EU
member states
my lords all people in this house would
agree that Small Boat Crossings should
be stopped Smugglers are profiting from
the desperation of people risking their
lives to reach our Shores also my lords
there is no doubt as to the size of the
challenge in dealing with the number of
Asylum Seekers already stuck in the
system as well as those currently making
their hair their way here right now
the main question we should address
ourselves to when looking at this bill
is will it make things better or will it
make them worse will this bill stop the
dangerous Crossings and lead to Serious
consequences for the people's people's
Smugglers will this bill protect those
most at risk from exploitation violence
and torture does it protect children
does it help those who we have made
promises to like Afghan interpreters who
missed the last flight from from Kabul
will this bill ensure we create safe
routes they say assignment Seekers must
use instead of using Channel Crossings
but safe routes which hardly exist at
all does this bill deal with the large
backlog of Asylum claims which continue
to build up and will it prevent people
from getting stuck in accommodation and
hotels waiting seemingly seemingly
indefinitely for their Asylum decision
does this bill maintain our
long-standing commitments to
International cooperation and law does
it maintain our International reputation
as a fair country that takes our role in
the International Community seriously
members across the house have provided
many answers to those questions
they have said this bill will not help
it will hurt and it is indeed a worrying
bill it will further damage our Asylum
system trap more people in limbo within
it and result in even higher costs it
will hurt children traffic men and women
and those fleeing War who are unable to
take safe routes to get here it will
hurt our International reputation and
our reputations with countries across
the world it won't provide real
consequence for the people Smugglers
profiting from Human misery on our
Shores my laws we will work across the
house to amend this bill so we maintain
the current levels of judicial oversight
we live up to our International
obligations and we maintain the original
principles of the modern slavery Act
I'm grateful to all Noble Lords who have
spoken today
it is a measure of the importance of the
issue before us that there have been
some 80 speakers in this debate
as we've heard from Noble Lords across
the house
as well as from my right honorable
friends the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary
it is clear that we must stop the boats
that much at least is Common Ground
our approach is driven
by a desire to do right by the people of
this country
and it is Guided by that most British of
principles
fairness
because the present situation is
anything but fair
the case for decisive action could not
be clearer
I say again ours is a generous and
compassionate country
we will continue offering sanctuary and
refuge to those fleeing persecution
conflict and tyranny
but what we will not accept is mass
illegal migration to our Shores
and that is why we need this bill to
stop the boats and address this
challenge once and for all
I turn now to the matters raised in the
debate including the points addressed in
the amendment moved by the noble Lord
Lord Paddock
first the most Reverend primate the
Archbishop of Canterbury and other Noble
Lords were a right to place the bill in
its moral context
proceeding with this bill is the moral
cause
we must put a stop to the dangerous
channeled Crossings putting lives at
risk and splitting families
we must end the callous exploitation of
vulnerable people by the people
Smugglers
and we must uphold the law and ensure
fair play for those who abide by our
immigration rules
a number of noble Lords commented on the
fact that on the introduction of this
pill in your lordship's house I made a
statement under section 191b of the
Human Rights Act
I think it's fair to say that there has
been a misunderstanding as to the effect
of a section 19 1B statement
we have designed a scheme that is novel
and ambitious
as a result we have made a section 19 1B
statement under that act
this simply makes clear that we cannot
say definitively that we will win a
challenge in Strasbourg however we are
confident that Strasbourg will respect
the will of Parliament and our Domestic
Court processes
we make no apologies for taking this
approach this is what the situation
demands and what the British public
expect
section 191b statements have been made
by governments of all stripes
I might add one was made by the then
Deputy Prime Minister Nick Clegg when
bringing forward the House of Lords
Reform Bill in 2012.
Tessa jowl similarly made a section
191b's statement in what became the
communications Act 2003.
it is noteworthy that when that act was
later challenged in the European Court
of human rights that Court found in the
animal Defenders case that there was no
violation of the convention
a number of noble Lords including the
noble Lord Lord Cashman and the noble
baroness lady ludford argued that this
bill breaches our International
obligations
there was some equally forthright
contributions making the contrary and in
my view very persuasive case
from my Noble friends Lord Howard limpny
Lord Lamont Lord Wilson King's Council
Lord Sandhurst King's Council drawing
some of them on the work of Professor
eakins King's Council and others at
policy exchange who've written
extensively on this topic
the government takes its International
obligations
including under the echr very seriously
and there is nothing in the bill
including in Clause 53 that requires the
UK to breach its International
obligations
in any event it is not correct that a
failure to comply with interim measures
invariably involves a breach of
international law
there are exceptional circumstances
where non-compliance with an interim
measure is not a breach of international
law
the noble baroness lady Lister and the
right Reverend the bishop of Durham and
the noble Lord Lord Alton amongst others
argued that the bill breaches the
refugee convention
I can assure the house that we are
satisfied the provisions in the bill
comply with the refugee convention
it is a long-standing principle that
those in need of protection should claim
Asylum at the earliest opportunity in
the first safe country they reach this
is an established part of international
Asylum procedures and applied across the
EU such as through the common European
Asylum system
this concept seeks to ensure that
migration from safe countries does not
undermine concerted efforts to help
those most in need
plainly all illegal arrivals across the
channel come from a safe country mostly
France
as my Noble friend Lord Dobbs and the
noble and learned Lord Brown have eaten
under Hayward rightly pointed out their
lives are not in danger in France
and they are taking the place of those
in genuine need
in December the high court upheld the
lawfulness of this principle
that those in need of protection should
claim asylum in the first safe country
they reach concluding that the
government can relocate Asylum Seekers
to Rwanda for their claims to be
determined by Rwanda rather than by the
United Kingdom
we look forward to the court of appeals
judgment on this question in the near
future
I think this addresses the concerns in
this regard expressed by various Noble
Lords including Lord Brown of ladyton
Lord Harris of Newport and the noble
baroness Lady Jones
we have always made clear that no one
will be returned or removed to a country
where they may be persecuted this will
not change
the noble Lord Lord German argued that
in disapplying Section 3 of The Human
Rights Act 1998 the bill was
transferring powers from Parliament and
the courts to the Secretary of State
my lords the opposite is the case
the Human Rights Act especially Section
3 has in some cases shifted the balance
away from Parliament towards the courts
we are already proposing to repeal
Section 3 of The Human Rights Act in the
Bill of Rights so our courts are no
longer required by that act to rewrite
legislation passed by this Parliament
ahead of wider reforms to our human
rights framework we are implementing
this disapplication to the provisions of
this bill to avoid courts adopting an
interpretation which is inconsistent
with parliament's intentions
a number of Nobel peers including my
Noble friend baroness helich have been
laboring under a misapprehension that
the bill removes judicial oversight
I would invite those who think this
carefully to read the relevant Clauses
of the bill
in all cases individuals will have the
opportunity to make suspensive claims
with judicial oversight in the upper
Tribunal
these claims are suspensive of removal
in all cases
in all cases individuals can Institute
other legal challenges including
judicial reviews on human rights grounds
in the normal way however these claims
are non-suspensive of removal
these claims can continue remotely as
they have done historically for other
immigration claims for example in the
case of the refusal of a spousal entry
clearance application
I might also add that the bill provides
for continued judicial oversight of
detention as it will be open to any
detainee at any time to apply to the
high court for a writ of habeas corpus
or its equivalent in Scotland
many noble Lords including the noble
Lord Lord hunt of King's Heath question
whether there is evidence of the misuse
of our modern slavery protections
the modern slavery Clauses are
fundamentally about preventing dangerous
and illegal crossings that pose a threat
to public order
however it is clear that the national
referral mechanism offers world-leading
protections to victims of modern slavery
and we must be alert to the risk that
these protections will be used to
frustrate removal action
last year
17 000 referrals took on average
543 days to reach a conclusive Grant
decision
making modern slavery protections
susceptible to misuse
modern slavery referrals from detention
and prison have also increased in 2020
27 that's 1005 of the people detained
within the UK following immigration
offenses were referred as potential
victims of modern slavery
and only one percent of individuals
detained within the UK following an
immigration offense who made a modern
slavery claim only one percent of
individuals who were detained within the
UK following an immigration offense
uh who made a modern slavery claim were
returned
the nrm referral rate for people
arriving in the UK on small boats and
being detained for return has risen from
six percent
50 people of detentions ending in 2019
to 73 percent in 2021
the referral rate has since Fallen
slightly to 65 percent between January
to September 2022
in contrast
where people were not detained for
return less than three percent of people
who arrived in the UK on small boats in
2021 were referred to the nrm within
three months
of entering the UK
modern slavery laws are therefore an
inextricable part of an immigration
system that is open to being misused in
order to block removals
my Noble friends uh lady Mubarak and
ladies trout as well as other Noble
Lords including the right Reverend
prelate the bishop of Gloucester
expressed concerns about the impact of
the bill on victims of modern slavery
the government is committed to tackling
the heinous crime of modern slavery and
supporting victims
ensures that individuals who arrive in
the UK illegally will no longer have the
potential to misuse modern slavery
protections to thwart their removal from
the UK
the measures are not a blanket approach
if a person needs to stay in the UK to
help support an investigation into and
the prosecution of their people
traffickers they will be exempt
if someone is identified as a potential
victim of modern slavery the government
will ensure that they are safely
returned to their home country where
possible or to another safe Third
Country like Rwanda
this will mean that trafficking victims
are given modern slavery support and
traffickers can be brought to Justice
while preventing people from abusing our
modern slavery laws
these Provisions are consistent with our
International obligations indeed under
Article 13 of ecat the UK has a right to
disqualify individuals who pose a threat
to public order
however we recognize that this is a
significant step and this is why the
modern slavery Provisions in the bill
are time Limited
I'm less renewed they will cease to
apply after two years
as many as a good many noble Lords
including my Noble friend Lord Bourne of
aberystwyth argued the solution to the
more small boats problem is to open up
more safe and legal routes
I am sorry to say that this is of itself
no answer
the UK has a long and proud history of
supporting refugees and we are committed
to maintaining clear well-defined
Global safe and legal routes for people
in need of protection
the UK working with the unhcr currently
operates a number of safe and legal
routes which support people directly
from regions of conflict and instability
in addition we operate the
country-specific schemes for those who
are eligible from Afghanistan Ukraine
and Hong Kong
but with Worldwide Refugee displacement
as observed during the debate now
standing at around 100 million the
United Kingdom cannot help everyone a
point I think on which there is
agreement around much of the house
it is important to add that those
seeking protection should claim asylum
in the first safe country this is the
fastest route to safety
the Prime Minister has committed to
introduce a cap on the number of people
coming by a safe and legal routes which
will be based on the capacity of our
local authorities agreed by Parliament
and amendable in the event of
humanitarian crises
the bill delivers this and I welcome the
support from the front bench opposite
for the principle of a cap
I too well remember the most Reverend
prelit for proposing such a cap during
his debate in December
the cap is necessary if we are to ensure
that the number of individuals we
welcome through safe and legal routes do
not exceed the capacity of the UK to
integrate and accommodate them
effectively appoint well made by my
Noble friend Lord farmer in respect of
stretched Children's Services
this is the right way to ensure that we
can continue to provide Sanctuary to
those in need of international
protection as part of a well-managed and
sustainable migration system
as now provided for in the bill the
government will publish a report within
six months of Royal Ascent on current
and any proposed additional safe and
legal routes and I repeat we will
Implement those new routes by the end of
next year
a number of noble Lords including the
noble Lord Lord scriven and the naval
baroness lady Brinton argued for the
exclusion of children from the duty to
remove or their detention powers in the
bill
we also heard calls to exclude pregnant
women from the detention powers
I'm glad to tell the house that to date
there have been very few pregnant women
in the small boats
let me say to the house that such a move
would only serve to incentivize the
people's Smugglers to Target to Target
particular groups or those with certain
characteristics the result could well be
that more children and pregnant women
are put into flimsy baits putting more
young lives at risk splitting up
families and encouraging adults to make
false claims that they are a child
I I can assure your Lordships has that
families will be kept together wherever
possible and that children will be
detained for as short a period as
possible
in age-appropriate accommodation
moreover as we have already made clear
our policy is not to arrange to remove
unaccompanied children before they turn
18 save in very limited circumstances as
Now set out on the face of the bill
for example for the purpose of reunion
with a parent or aware removal it is to
a safe country of origin they may only
be detained in specific circumstances to
be prescribed in regulations
on the issue of detention more broadly
contrary to what a number of noble Lords
opposite has said the bill does not
provide for indefinite detention it does
enable detention for the purposes of
removal and in doing so codifies in part
the long-standing common law principles
governing immigration detention
including that a person may only be
detained for a period that is reasonable
in all the circumstances
they will not be as the noble baroness
lady chakrabarti put it interned in
legal limbo indefinitely
the noble baroness lady Lister expressed
concerns regarding the provision
strengthening scientific age assessment
methods
it is critical that the government takes
action to disincentivize individuals who
are deliberately misrepresenting their
ages in order to cheat the system as
well as protecting genuine children
determining the age of a young person is
an inherently difficult task and we are
aware that no single age assessment
method scientific or not which can
determine an individual's age with
precision
however we believe that considering a
wider range of evidence will enable more
informed and robust decisions
I can assure the house that regulations
under Clause 56 will not be made to
introduce an automatic Assumption of
adulthood until the science is
sufficiently accurate to support such a
finding moreover the Assumption will
only be applied in the circumstances set
out in regulations if an individual
refuses to undergo the scientific age
assessment without good reason
it is important to note that negative
consequences such as automatic
assumptions are applied with Variations
by echr signatories including the
Netherlands Luxembourg Poland Slovakia
and the Czech Republic
so it is the UK which is the outlier as
one of very few European countries that
does not currently employ scientific
methods such as x-rays as part of age
assessments
the noble Lord Lord Coker and others
asked about the detention capacity
required to give effect to the bill
purpose of the bill is to deter people
from coming to the UK illegally as they
know they will be swiftly returned to
their home country if it is safe to do
so or to a safe Third Country when the
bill is implemented this will mean that
numbers will start to come down and that
will reduce pressure on accommodation
and services in the UK
we are absolutely committed to making
this legislation work and to find
further solutions to scale up our
detention capacity but the first step is
this change in the law and which is why
we are focused on getting this bill
through the house
various Noble Lords challenge the
deterrent effect of the bill we've
always said there is no one single
solution to the global migration crisis
and certainly no overnight fix
but doing nothing is not an option
the bill will remove the incentive to
pay criminal gangs and attempt dangerous
Channel Crossings in the hopes of
settling in the UK the bills Provisions
are designed to deter such dangerous and
illegal activity
the neighbor Lord horm reminded us of
the instructive Australian experience of
what happens when illegal roots are
rendered unviable and as the noble and
learned Lord Brown have eaten under
Haywood correctly warned every amendment
to soften the bill will weaken its
objectives
my Noble friend baroness Lawler put it
well this bill is stringent but
necessary and proportionate
but it is not the only step we're taking
it comes alongside our partnership with
Rwanda bolstered enforcement action to
Bear Down on the criminal gangs and then
there is the cooperation with France as
my Noble friend Lord Howard of Liberty
right rightly pointed out
my Lord's this government will always
act in the interests of the law-abiding
majority
that means that securing our borders it
means delivering a fair and effective
immigration and Asylum system and it
means stopping the votes enough is
enough the British people want this
problem dealt with
this bill will enable us to do exactly
that and I commend it to the house and
invite Noble Lords to reject the
amendment standing in the name of the
noble Lord Lord Paddock
my Lord's our recent Amendment sets out
why this house should decline to give
this bill a second reading contrary to
the assertions made by the noble law the
minister we believe that bill undermines
the rule of law by failing to meet the
United Kingdom's international law
commitments and by allowing ministers to
ignore the directions of judges it
undermines the UK's tradition of
providing Sanctuary to refugees by
removing the ability of refugees to
exercise their rights their legal right
to claim Asylum by removing protections
affording afforded to Modern slavery
victims and by increasing the number of
people in indefinite detention including
children
it fails to provide safe and legal
routes of refugees it fails to include
measures to eliminate the backlog of
Asylum cases and it fails to include
measures to tackle people smuggling
ganks
I'm grateful to my Noble friend baroness
Thomas of Winchester for pointing out
that when in 2007 the former labor
government passed the fraud trials
without a jury bill in the other place
by a similar majority to this bill
the house of laws carried a fatal motion
at second reading
the bill was never reintroduced
the list of those Noble Lords who voted
against its second reading is
Illuminating
and included two Bishops
the noble Lord Lord Forsyth of Drumline
who earlier today described overturning
the will of the other place as and I
quote a complete abuse of this house
and I quote and I don't I didn't think
any members of this house who respect
the rules of this house and its role
could possibly go through the lobbies
and vote for that Amendment must have
had a road to Damascus experience no I'm
not going to give way I'm sorry
[Applause]
I'm grateful to the noble Lord I'm sure
he wouldn't want to mislead the house
he's obviously looked into that matter
that motion was the
consideration of second reading should
be deferred by six months not that the
bill should be destroyed
and the noble and the noble Lord will
know exactly what Erskine May says about
the motion that was passed which is that
Parliament considers that to be a fatal
motion against the bills
and 123 other conservatives also voted
in favor of refusing the bill a second
reading including 59 who are still
sitting members of this house
perhaps they have also changed their
minds and perhaps when they find
themselves in opposition they'll change
their minds again
my laws if I thought this bill would
stop the boats I would not seek to
divide this house but it does it doesn't
it did not it does not
it is not likely to stop the boats
this bill is all pain and no gain
this is a question of principle and I
wish to test the opinion of the house
question is that the amendment in the
name of Lord be agreed to as many as of
that opinion will say content
a country not content
I think we're not contents have it
the matter will be decided by a Division
I would advise the house when the Voting
is open
[Music]
voting is now open clear the VA